READY, FREDDIE. OKAY. NOW. MY
GAVEL. SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US FOR THIS MEETING. THE
SENATE WELCOMES THE PUBLIC IN
PERSON, AND WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE Þ
STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BE
PRESENT IN ROOM 2200 SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH OUR QUORUM AND BEGIN
OUR HEARING, WELL, WE'LL BEGIN
ANYWAY. RIGHT WE HAVE EIGHT
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA WITH
THREE BILLS ON CONSENT. FIRST,
PLEASE NOTE THAT ITEM SIX, SB
1291, HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA. THE FOLLOWING
THREE BILLS ARE ON CONSENT. ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB 994. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR, SB 1169, AND ITEM SEVEN SB
1405. IN ADDITION, ITEM EIGHT,
SB 1439 BY SENATOR ASHBY WILL BE
PRESENTED BY SENATOR ATKINS. DO
WE SAY NO, AND WE SEE THAT WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE WILL
OPERATE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE, LET'S
SEE. OKAY. NOW LET'S HEAR FROM
OUR FIRST AUTHOR. I THINK THAT
WILL BE. YES. SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR,
CABALLERO, YOU COULD EITHER DO
YOUR OWN FIRST OR SENATOR
PADILLA'S. I'LL START WITH
SENATOR BY THE. YES, IN FRONT OF
ME. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MISS, MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
AS AS I INDICATED, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL 1072 ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR PADILLA. DUE
TO THE IMPACTS OF REPEATED
DROUGHTS AND CLIMATE CHANGE,
POTABLE WATER HAS BECOME SCARCE
AND WATER CONSERVATION HAS
BECOME NECESSARY. RETAIL WATER
AND WASTEWATER AGENCIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE ARE FACING
LEGAL CHALLENGES TO THEIR
SERVICE FEE STRUCTURE, AS THEY
CHARGE HIGHER FEES FOR RESIDENTS
AND CONSUMERS THAT USE EXCESSIVE
WATER. THESE CHALLENGES ARE
BASED ON PROPOSITION TWO 818.
SUBSTANTIVE LIMITATIONS,
SPECIFICALLY, THE COST OF
SERVICE AND PROPORTIONALITY
PROVISIONS. OFTEN, CHALLENGERS
ARE HIGH WATER USERS WHO CLAIM
THE CHARGES ARE NOT
PROPORTIONAL, AND THESE HIGH
WATER USERS DEMAND A REFUND. IN
LITIGATION, HOWEVER, REFUNDS ARE
NOT EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED BY
PROPOSITION 218. SINCE
PROPOSITION 218 AMENDED THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION IN 1996,
COURTS HAVE REMEDIED VIOLATIONS
THROUGH WRITS OF MANDATE,
DECLARATORY RELIEF, AND
INJUNCTIVE RELIEF. THESE
PROSPECTIVE REMEDIES ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THE VIOLATION BY
DIRECTING THE AGENCY AGENCY TO
REFORM ITS RATE APPROACH GOING
FORWARD WITH EXCESS REVENUES
USED TO REMEDIATE FUTURE COST OF
SERVICE. YET AS OF JANUARY 2024,
THERE ARE AT LEAST THREE CASES
UNDER UNDER CONSIDERATION BY THE
CALIFORNIA COURTS OF APPEAL. IN
SENATOR PADILLA'S DISTRICT,
WHERE THE VALIDITY OF REFUNDS AS
A REMEDY IS AT ISSUE. THESE
CASES THREATEN THE SOLVENCY OF
LOCAL PUBLIC AGENCIES BECAUSE OF
A REFUND REMEDY WERE GRANTED. IT
WOULD OPERATE RETRO, ACTIVELY
CREATING AN EXTREME FINANCIAL
BURDEN FOR THE AGENCY IN
QUESTION. PUBLIC WATER DISTRICTS
OFTEN HAVE NO REVENUE SOURCE
OTHER THAN THEIR RATES AND
CHARGES. A PUBLIC AGENCY SETS
ITS CHARGES TO MERELY COVER
COSTS ANNUALLY AND RECEIVES NO
PROFIT, SO ANY REFUND WOULD NEED
TO BE FUNDED BY RAISING RATES ON
FUTURE TAXPAYERS. SB 1072 WOULD
CLARIFY EXISTING LAW THAT IF A
COURT DETERMINES THAT AN EXCESS
FEE HAS BEEN CHARGED, THE AGENCY
MUST CREDIT THAT AMOUNT AGAINST
THE COST OF PROVIDING THE
SERVICE. LET'S BE CLEAR THIS IS
A MATTER OF EQUITY. SB 1072
ENSURES THAT LOW INCOME WATER
USERS ARE NOT SUBSIDIZING HIGH
INCOME WATER ISSUES BECAUSE
THESE LAWSUITS ARE BROUGHT ON BY
LARGE WATER USERS, ANY REFUND
PROVIDED RETROACTIVELY WOULD
INEVITABLY HIT LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS THE HARDEST. SB 1072
IS A CRITICAL PROTECTION FOR
PUBLIC AGENCIES AS THEY ADDRESS
THE FEE CHALLENGES. IT'S VITAL
THAT PEOPLE GET THE MONEY THEY
ARE DUE WHILE WE PROVIDE OUR
AGENCY WITH THE FLEXIBLE
FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED TO OPERATE
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OUR CLARE COLLINS, PARTNER AT
HANSON BRIDGETT AND SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO THE OTAY OTAY WATER
DISTRICT AND MAURA TOP,
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. WELL, WELCOME, AND WE
WILL GIVE, TWO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH. YEP. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CLAIRE COLLINS. I AM A
PARTNER AT THE LAW FIRM OF
HANSON BRIDGETT, WHERE I AM THE
CHAIR OF THE PUBLIC REVENUE
GROUP AND I'M ALSO SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO OTAY WATER DISTRICT
WATER FOR WASTE, WATER AND SOLID
WASTE ARE ESSENTIAL PUBLIC
SERVICES, AND THAT ARE PRIMARILY
PROVIDED BY PUBLIC ENTITIES.
APPROXIMATELY 90% OF THE STATE'S
WATER WASTEWATER IS PROVIDED BY
PUBLIC ENTITIES. BECAUSE THEY
ARE PUBLIC, THEY CANNOT MAKE A
PROFIT, THEY ARE REVENUE
NEUTRAL, AND THEY HAVE NO
SHAREHOLDERS THAT WOULD DERIVE A
BENEFIT FROM A PROFIT. WHEN
COLLECTING FEES FOR THEIR
SERVICES, THEY ESTIMATE THE
TOTAL AMOUNT NEEDED TO PROVIDE
THAT SERVICE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
AND THROUGHOUT THEIR SERVICE
AREA. AND THEN THEY DIVIDE THOSE
COSTS PROPORTIONALLY AMONG THEIR
CUSTOMERS BASED ON THOSE
CUSTOMERS, CUSTOMER TYPE AND
THEIR AMOUNT OF USE. THE
HALLMARK OF THIS SYSTEM UNDER
PROP 218 IS THAT EACH USER PAYS
ITS PROPORTIONATE, FAIR SHARE OF
THE OVERALL COST OF SERVICE. BUT
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO,
INCREASING LAWSUITS FROM HIGH
WATER USERS, CLAIMING THAT THEY
ARE PAYING MORE THAN THEIR FAIR
SHARE. THEY DEMAND REFUNDS AND
LITIGATION, WHICH, IF AWARDED,
WOULD REQUIRE THAT PUBLIC
AGENCIES RAISE THEIR FUTURE
RATES IN ORDER TO PAY BACK PRIOR
WATER USERS. IN SOME CASES, THIS
AS MUCH AS 40% MORE IN A GIVEN
YEAR. AS A RESULT, EVERYONE'S
CHARGES WILL GO UP IN THE FUTURE
IN ORDER TO PAY BACK THE PAST.
THERE IS NO REPORTED CASE THAT
PROVIDES FOR A REFUND AND
PROPOSITION 218 DOES ALLOW THE
LEGISLATURE TO MAKE LAW
IMPLEMENTING PROP 218. AND IN
FACT, THAT LAW IS CALLED THE
PROPOSITION 218 OMNIBUS
IMPLEMENTATION ACT, AND THE, THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DONE SO MULTIPLE
TIMES IN THE PAST, AN APPROACH
THAT PROVIDES FOR OFFSETS
INSTEAD IS WHAT'S PROPOSED IN
THIS BILL. IT WOULD PROVIDE FOR
AN OFFSET AGAINST FUTURE RATES
INSTEAD OF A RETROSPECTIVE
REFUND. A SIMILAR LAW EXISTS
WITH RESPECT TO SOMETHING CALLED
CAPACITY FEES, WHICH IS THE
OTHER PRIMARY FORM OF REVENUES
THAT WATER AND WASTEWATER
AGENCIES DERIVE FROM THEIR
USERS. GOVERNMENT CODE 66016
PROHIBITS REFUNDS FOR CAPACITY
FEES. AND INSTEAD PROVIDES FOR
THE PROSPECTIVE OFFSET SIMILAR
TO THIS BILL. IF YOU COULD WRAP
IT UP, PLEASE. SURE. IN THIS
WAY, THE AGGRIEVED RATEPAYERS
RETAIN A REMEDY AND THE PUBLIC
SERVICE PROVIDER RETAINS
PREDICTABILITY. THANK YOU AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
MOIRA TOP HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO. WE'RE A
CO-SPONSOR ON THIS MEASURE. AND
IN SAN DIEGO WE ALWAYS SAY THAT
WE ARE AT THE END OF THE PIPE.
IN CALIFORNIA, THE DROP STOPS
WITH US, AND ENSURING FAIRNESS
AND EQUITY IS A PARAMOUNT,
CONCERN AS THE CITY SETS ITS
RATES FOR ITS MILLIONS OF
RATEPAYERS IN THE CITY, WE'RE
DOING THIS ALL THE WHILE. WE ARE
MEETING OUR CONSERVATION WATER
CONSERVATION GOALS AND
DEVELOPING NEW AND SUSTAINABLE
WATER SOURCES. SO WE'RE NOT AS
RELIANT ON WATER FROM OUTSIDE
OUR JURISDICTION, AND SO WHILE
I'M GOING TO DEFER TO, TO MISS
COLLINS, WHO'S THE, EXPERT
LAWYER ON ON THE CASES BEFORE
COURTS, AND OUR NEIGHBORING,
SISTER WATER AGENCY, I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS,
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE, IS THAT
THIS IS CLARIFYING. WE SEE THIS
AS A CLARIFYING MEASURE FOR THE
COURTS TO ENSURE THAT THAT
PARAMOUNT GOAL OF EQUITY AND
FAIRNESS IS EMPLOYED WITHIN THE
CITY, AND SO WE ARE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR PADILLA AND
SENATOR CABALLERO FOR, FOR,
HELPING US OUT TODAY, BUT ON
BEHALF OF MAYOR TODD GLORIA AND
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO, WE DO ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY, ARE THERE ANY
OTHER SUPPORT WITNESSES WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ME, TO YOU NAME AN
ORGANIZATION? GOOD MORNING. I'M
ERIC LARA, SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS MARKUS DETWEILER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
DENNIS ALBIANI, ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CLARITA VALLEY WATER
AGENCY, WE SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING. JAY JEFFERSON WITH
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING, KYLIE WRIGHT, ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING. BALTAZAR CONEJO,
LOBBYIST FOR OTAY WATER
DISTRICT, IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING, KEISHA KUMAR,
SENATE DISTRICT ONE, RESIDENT
AND UC DAVIS LAW STUDENT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU, WE
CAN. SHALL WE DO THE QUORUM NOW?
YEAH. OKAY THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY, WE'LL DO ROLL CALL.
SENATORS DURAZO HERE. DURAZO
PRESENT. SEYARTO HERE. SATO.
PRESENT. DOLLY. DOLLY. PRESENT
GLAZER. SKINNER. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
PRESENT. WIENER. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU. OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION, WITNESSES,
IF YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE UP TO TWO
MINUTES, I'LL BE, SCOTT KAUFMAN,
HOWARD JARVIS, TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION. I'LL BE QUICK.
PROPOSITION 218 IS NOT A COMPLEX
STATUTE. IT IS PART OF THE
CONSTITUTION. A STATUTE CANNOT
BE USED TO AMEND OR OTHERWISE
SUPPLANT THE CONSTITUTION
FURTHER, THERE IS A HUGE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CREDIT FOR
FUTURE CHARGES AND AN ACTUAL
REFUND. ARTICLE 13 D SECTION 6B3
PROVIDES THE AMOUNT OF A FEE OR
CHARGE IMPOSED ON ANY PARCEL OR
PERSON AS AN INCIDENT OF
PROPERTY OWNERSHIP SHALL NOT
EXCEED THE PROPORTIONAL COST OF
THE SERVICE ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE
PARCEL. IF A TAXPAYER MOVES, HOW
WILL HE OR SHE BE COMPENSATED
FOR A VIOLATION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS UNDER 6B3?
IF THE AGENCY MERELY APPLIES THE
OVERCHARGE TO REDUCE RATES PAID
BY OTHERS IN THE FUTURE? WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE EXCLUSIVE
REMEDY IS IMPOSSIBLE? THESE ARE
NOT DAMAGES. THESE ARE REFUNDS
AND REFUNDS GO BACK TO THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE ILLEGALLY
FORCED TO PAY THEM, THE
COMMITTEE'S OWN STAFF REPORT
NOTES THAT IF THIS BILL BECOMES
LAW, RATEPAYERS THAT OVERPAID
WOULD NOT GET THEIR MONEY BACK.
MONEY OWED AND NOT RETURNED IS A
TAKINGS VIOLATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY, OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES. OKAY.
SEEING NONE, WE'RE GOING TO
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
YES, SENATOR. DARLING. SO JUST A
QUESTION. SO THIS IS SO ISN'T
THERE A COURT CASE? ISN'T THERE
ISN'T THIS IN THE COURTS RIGHT
NOW? AND SO, YES. AREN'T THEY
GOING TO DECIDE WHETHER THERE IS
THERE REALLY NECESSARY TO HAVE
THIS BILL EVEN THOUGH THERE'S A
COURT CASE THEY'RE GOING TO
DECIDE WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN,
RIGHT AT SOME POINT. THERE ARE
THREE COURT CASES PENDING RIGHT
NOW. THAT'S CORRECT. O-TAY. SAN
DIEGO AND COACHELLA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT AND THE COURTS, AT SOME
POINT MAY DECIDE THE REFUND
ISSUE. YES IT IS. IT IS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT WITHIN THOSE
CASES. OKAY. SO NOW I HAVE A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. SO OR MAYBE
JUST A COMMENT, I DON'T THIS IS
A COMPLICATED ISSUE, AND IT'S
I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY. RIGHT SO I
REPRESENT LAKE TAHOE AND DURING
THE DROUGHT, WE HAD THE
BILLIONAIRES WHO KICKED OUT ALL
THE MILLIONAIRES NOW, AND WE
WERE TRYING TO REGULATE WATER.
WE HAD AN ORDER FROM THE STATE
TO REGULATE WATER. AND, YOU
KNOW, WE THEY STARTED OUT FINING
THEM SO MUCH PER GALLON OR
WHATEVER, OR 100 GALLONS AND
THEN PRETTY MUCH SO MUCH A DAY,
AND PRETTY SOON IT WAS $10,000 A
DAY AND THEY WERE PAYING IT.
THEY DIDN'T CARE. WHEN THEY
COME, THEY WANT TO PLAY CROQUET
ON THEIR GIANT HALF ACRE LAWN.
AND THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THE
COST IS. AT THE SAME TIME, OUR
REGULAR RESIDENTS THERE WERE
CONSERVING WATER, AND SO IT WAS
A REAL PROBLEM TO TRY TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO LIKE, REIN THESE
PEOPLE IN. BUT THEY'RE SO
WEALTHY, THEY JUST DON'T CARE,
SO IS THAT THE CASE HERE WHERE
YOU HAVE WHERE YOU HAVE
CONSUMPTION, WHERE PEOPLE JUST
ARE USING WHAT THEY WANT TO USE
AND THEY'RE PAYING FOR IT,
THEY'RE PAYING A GRADUATED RATE,
I SHOULD SAY. AND THEN SO I TALK
TO ME A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW THE
PERSON THAT'S MEETING THEIR
GOAL, THE LOWER THE LOWER PEOPLE
AND THEN THE WEALTHIER PEOPLE
ARE LIKE DOING SOMETHING THAT'S
OUTSIDE THE BOX. SO I'M NOT
CLEAR ON THAT. SURE, I'M HAPPY
TO COMMENT ON THAT, TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS MAY BE GOING ON
HERE. AND UNFORTUNATELY, I'M
NOT, I'M NOT INTIMATELY FAMILIAR
WITH WHAT HAPPENED IN LAKE
TAHOE. BUT THERE ARE TWO
COMPONENTS OF THAT HIGH WATER
USE. ONE ELEMENT OF THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN PENALTIES. AND
PENALTIES ARE SORT OF OUTSIDE OF
PROP 218 OKAY. WHICH SAYS TAKE
THE WHOLE PIE. HOW MUCH MONEY DO
YOU HAVE TO SPEND TO PROVIDE
WATER TO ALL OF YOUR SERVICE
AREA IN A GIVEN YEAR, AND THEN
DIVIDE IT UP FAIRLY AND
PROPORTIONALLY AMONG THE USERS
ACCORDING TO THEIR USE? THAT IS
OUR GOAL, RIGHT? A FAIR SHARE
PROCESS. SO IF THE BILL WAIT,
WAIT, SO BUT IF SOMEBODY USES IF
ONE ONE CUSTOMER USES WHAT 30
CUSTOMERS WOULD USE THAT ONE
CUSTOMER IS NOT THAT BECAUSE THE
WHOLE PIE IS BIGGER AT THAT
POINT? THAT'S CORRECT.
ABSOLUTELY. THERE'S TWO MAJOR
COMPONENTS. WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
WATER RATES. THE FIRST COMPONENT
IS WHAT MOST PEOPLE THINK OF
VERY SIMPLY AS WELL. IF I BUY A
GALLON OF WATER, I PAY FOR A
GALLON OF WATER, RIGHT? AND IF I
BUY 20 GALLONS OF WATER AND
LET'S SAY A GALLON OF WATER IS
$1, IF I BUY ONE GALLON OF
WATER, IT SHOULD BE A DOLLAR.
BUY BUY 20 GALLONS OF WATER, IT
SHOULD BE $20. WE GENERALLY
AGREE WITH THAT, BUT THERE'S
SOME SUBTLETY. BUT WHAT THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT IS THAT WHEN YOU BUY 20
GALLONS OF WATER, YOU GO FROM A
PIPE THAT NEEDS TO BE THIS BIG
TO A PIPE THAT NEEDS TO BE THIS
BIG. SO THOSE COSTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THE MOLECULES OF
WATER ARE NOT NECESSARILY THE
COSTS OF SERVICE. THERE ARE ALSO
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, AND IN MANY OF THESE
CASES, THE ISSUE IS SHOULD THAT
HIGHER WATER USER PAY FOR SOME
PROPORTIONATELY HIGHER AMOUNT OF
THAT PIPE, NOT NECESSARILY THE
MOLECULE OF WATER. AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
EQUITY ON. BECAUSE IF EVERYONE
ELSE IS USING A VERY SMALL
AMOUNT CONSERVING. RIGHT. AND
THEY WE WOULD ONLY NEED A SMALL
PIPE. BUT THEN YOUR BILLIONAIRES
COME IN WITH THEIR CROQUET LAWNS
AND NOW WE HAVE TO BUILD A PIPE
THIS BIG. GENERALLY THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WITHIN EACH
OF THESE WATER DISTRICTS SAYS,
WELL, IF YOU'RE GOING TO PAY
YOUR FAIR SHARE, THEN YOU GOT TO
PAY YOUR FAIR SHARE OF THAT
BIGGER PIPE TO NOT JUST THE
BIGGER. SO IS THAT WHAT THE
COURT CASE IS ABOUT? CORRECT.
AND SO WHAT? HOW NOW EXPLAIN TO
ME HOW THIS BILL IS GOING TO
WHAT HOW IS IT? WHAT'S THIS
BILL? DO IT SAYS YOU GOT TO PAY
FOR THE LARGER PIPE IF YOU'RE
THE BIGGER USER. NO, SIR. IN
FACT, WHAT THIS SAYS IS IF AND
THERE'S A LOT OF MATH THAT GOES
INTO THIS, WE HAVE RATE STUDIES
THAT SUPPORT EVERY ONE OF THESE
RATE DETERMINATIONS. AND THESE
RATE STUDIES ARE BUILT OUT BY
ECONOMISTS AND ENGINEERS WHO ARE
TRYING TO FAIRLY ALLOCATE THESE
COSTS OF SERVICE RIGHT TO EACH
OF THE RATEPAYERS. AND WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS WE'VE SEEN BECAUSE
LO LO RATEPAYERS DON'T SUE, THEY
DON'T, YOU KNOW, THINK THEY'RE
PAYING TOO MUCH. IT'S HIGH WATER
USERS AND THEY'RE LIKE, GOLLY, I
DON'T WANT TO PAY FOR THAT
BIGGER PIPE. LET'S SAY. RIGHT,
YOU SHOULD SPLIT THE COST OF
THAT PIPE AMONG ALL OF THE USERS
EQUALLY. BUT THERE HAVE BEEN
LEGISLATIVE DETERMINATIONS MADE
BY INDIVIDUAL LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT MIGHT SAY, WELL, GOSH, WE
THINK WE SHOULD CHARGE A LITTLE
BIT MORE TO PEOPLE WHO USE MORE
PIPE. AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT. SO THEN IF THE
COURT DETERMINES THAT A REFUND
IS DUE BECAUSE THEY PAID FOR TOO
MUCH PIPE OR TOO MUCH WATER,
THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS WE DON'T
HAVE ANY EXTRA DOLLARS, RIGHT?
RIGHT. WE'VE I GET THAT PART
RIGHT. AND SO WHAT WE WOULD BE
DOING IS AND I'LL GIVE YOU THE
EXAMPLE OF OTAY, OTAY HAS ABOUT
$100 MILLION A YEAR BUDGET. THEY
SUPPLY 55,000 CONNECTIONS. IF
THE REFUNDS WERE TO TAKE PLACE
IN THIS LAWSUIT, THEY ARE
LOOKING AT, LET'S SAY, ABOUT $35
MILLION IN REFUNDS. SO WE NOW,
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO RAISE $100
MILLION NEXT YEAR, WE HAVE TO
RAISE $135 MILLION NEXT YEAR ON
RATEPAYERS. AND THAT'S GOING TO
BE SPREAD ACROSS, BECAUSE THAT'S
NOW A GENERAL FUND DEBT, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY'S PAYING SOMETHING.
EVERYBODY'S PAYING WHAT HAPPENS
IN THE CONNECTION FEE CONTEXT
AND CONNECTION FEES ARE WHEN YOU
COME INTO A SYSTEM AND YOU'VE
GOT TO BUILD A BIGGER PIPE,
RIGHT, IS THE LAW AND GOVERNMENT
CODE? 660168 SAYS YOU DON'T GET
A REFUND. WHAT YOU GET IS ANY
OVERAGE IF WE DETERMINE THERE'S
AN OVERAGE, GOES TO PAY DOWN THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS IN THE FUTURE.
SO NEXT YEAR, LET'S SAY, INSTEAD
WE COLLECTED DIFFERENT $100
MILLION. LET'S SAY WE HAD $100
MILLION BUDGET. WE COLLECTED
$110 MILLION, WE WOULD TAKE THAT
ADDITIONAL $10 MILLION, WHICH WE
DON'T NEED TO SPEND. WE'D PUT IT
IN RESERVES FOR A YEAR, AND THEN
NEXT YEAR WE WOULD ONLY COLLECT
90 MILLION. RIGHT. SO WE WOULD
CREATE THAT CREDITED OFFSET AND
THEN AGAIN ALLOCATE. THIS IS
LARGELY AN ACCOUNTING PROBLEM.
SENATOR. HOW DO WE ACCOUNT FOR
WHO OWES WHAT TO MAKE UP THAT
$100 MILLION? BUT WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS IF WE HAVE TO GO RAISE
$35 MILLION EXTRA, THAT'S A
THAT'S A REAL BURDEN ON EVERYONE
IN THE SYSTEM. AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO AVOID. SO TO THE
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION THAT SAYS
IT'S NOT, IT'S NOT IN LINE WITH
PROP 218, SO THE COURTS ARE
GOING TO WHEN THE COURTS DECIDE
THAT YOU'RE STUCK WITH WHATEVER
THE COURTS BASICALLY SAY, IF WE
DO THIS BILL, THERE'S GOING TO
BE A CONFLICT BETWEEN 218 AND
THIS BILL. WHAT I WOULD I
WOULDN'T AGREE WITH THAT. HOW
DOES THE BILL FIX IT? THAT'S
WHAT I'M TRYING TO GET AT. IF
YOU IF YOU PASS THE BILL AND THE
COURTS SAY THIS IS THE LAW, WHAT
OR THIS IS HOW THEY INTERPRET
218 WHAT DOES THIS BILL DO? SO
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO IS SAY
INSTEAD OF GOING AND COLLECTING
$35 MILLION, WE WOULD SAY, WELL,
WE'RE I GUESS PART OF THIS IS
WHERE IS THAT EXTRA $35 MILLION?
LET ME GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE.
WE TAKE A PIE, WE CUT IT INTO
PIECES. IF, IF A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
OVERPAID, THAT MEANS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF PEOPLE UNDERPAID,
RIGHT? BECAUSE OTHERWISE, WE
COULDN'T HAVE MADE THAT $100
MILLION UP. WHERE ARE WE GOING
TO COLLECT THAT EXTRA $35
MILLION? WE CAN'T GO BACK AS WE
REFUND, APPARENTLY, PAST
RATEPAYERS. HOW DO WE GO BACK
AND COLLECT THE UNDER
COLLECTIONS FROM THOSE PRIOR
RATEPAYERS? THIS IS A
FUNDAMENTAL PUBLIC REVENUE
PROBLEM. AND THE WAY IT'S BEEN
SOLVED IN THE PAST IS THROUGH
THE CONNECTION FEE APPROACH,
WHICH IS TO SAY, WELL, WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO REFUND IT,
CREDIT IT MOVING FORWARD. SO
WHAT CHANGES IS NOT SAYING THAT
THERE WASN'T A VIOLATION, BUT
FROM A PUBLIC POLICY STANDPOINT,
WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT THE AGENCY
HAS NECESSARILY DONE SOMETHING.
IT'S AN ACCOUNTING ISSUE. LET ME
JUST PUT IT THAT WAY. IT'S AN
ACCOUNTING ISSUE AND NO ONE'S
GETTING RICH OFF OF THIS. I
KNOW, BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO
SUPPLY WATER AND YOU STILL HAVE
TO PAY YOUR BILL. EXACTLY. AND
IF THE COURTS WEIGH IN, YOU'RE
STUCK. RIGHT. AND SO THE
QUESTION IS, DO WE WANT A PUBLIC
POLICY THAT SAYS IT'S OKAY FOR
US TO RAISE RATES ON EVERYONE IN
ORDER TO PAY BACK SOME? OR DO WE
WANT A SITUATION THAT SAYS THERE
WAS AN ACCOUNTING ISSUE HERE?
WE'RE GOING TO FIX THE
ACCOUNTING ISSUE GOING FORWARD,
AND WE'RE GOING TO CREDIT THE
WHOLE RATE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO DO
THAT. SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
HAPPENS NORMALLY IS THAT WE SAY,
OKAY, NEXT YEAR WE'RE GOING TO
FIX THESE PROBLEMS THE COURTS
TOLD US HAVE OCCURRED, AND WE
WILL FIX THEM GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE WE HAVE A HARD TIME
GOING BACK BECAUSE HOW DO WE
REBALANCE THAT ENTIRE ACCOUNTING
? OKAY. YES, SENATOR. ALL RIGHT,
I NEED A COUPLE OF
CLARIFICATIONS. WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT MAIN LINES? ARE
YOU TALKING ABOUT THE FEEDER
LINES THAT GO TO THE CONNECTION
FEES? BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ITSELF, THAT'S A FIXED COST.
THAT FIXED COST IS WHATEVER IT
COSTS TO PUT IT IN. AND THEN THE
WATER USAGE FROM THEN ON IS THE
MOVEABLE COST, RIGHT. OUR FIXED
COSTS, WILL CHANGE OVER TIME
BECAUSE CAPACITY HAS TO BE
ENHANCED. SO WE HAVE TO BUILD
BIGGER SYSTEMS. SO THAT'S WHAT I
WANTED TO GET AT. SO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IS, IS THE QUESTION IS
ABOUT THE MAIN LINE SYSTEM THAT
YOU HAD TO UPGRADE BECAUSE THE
FEEDER LINES WERE BEING PUT IN
THAT WERE TOO BIG FOR THESE
LARGER USERS, BECAUSE IF I'M
GOING TO BE A LARGER USER AND I
HAVE TO GET GET WATER FROM THE
MAIN LINE, WELL, USUALLY THE
MAIN LINES HAVE BEEN DESIGNED
AROUND WHAT IS GOING TO BE IN
THE FUTURE. YES, SIR. SO WE PUT
MAIN LINES DOWN SOME STREETS IN
MURIETTA THAT WERE WAY LARGER
THAN PEOPLE THOUGHT WE NEEDED,
BECAUSE IN THE FUTURE WE WOULD
NEED IT AT. AND, AND THEN YOU
TAKE YOUR FEEDER LINES, AND YOUR
FEEDER LINES ARE BASED ON WHAT
SIZE, PROPERTY AND WHAT KIND OF
USAGE YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE.
WHICH ONES ARE YOU TRYING TO
HAVE THEM PAY FOR BECAUSE THE
FEEDER LINES WERE ALWAYS
ABSORBED BY THE DEVELOPER,
CORRECT. AND THE PERSON THAT IS
GOING TO BE USING THAT PROPERTY?
ABSOLUTELY, SENATOR. YOU'RE
RIGHT. AND THAT'S PART OF WHAT
CAPACITY FEES PAY FOR. IS THAT
LARGER SIZING IN ADDITION TO THE
LARGER SIZE. AND THAT WE
CONSTANTLY HAVE TO BUILD LARGER
SIZING BECAUSE THERE'S
INCREMENTAL GROWTH OVER TIME.
RIGHT. WE USE MORE WATER AS A
SYSTEM AS THE SYSTEMS GET
BIGGER. BUT WE ALSO HAVE CAPITAL
COSTS THAT RELATE TO OPERATING
AND MAINTAINING THOSE LINES. SO
I WOULD THAT ONE OTHER EXAMPLE
IS IF YOU GO FROM A LINE THAT'S
THIS BIG TO A LINE THAT'S THIS
BIG, IT'S NOT JUST THE COST OF
THE STEEL AND THE DIRT. RIGHT TO
BUILD THAT LINE. IT'S ALSO THE
ONGOING COST OF OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE TO THE ONGOING COST
OF ELECTRICITY TO PUMP WATER
THROUGH THAT LINE. AND SO THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT,
AGAIN, AREN'T RELATED
NECESSARILY TO THE MOLECULES OF
WATER, BUT THAT ARE RELATED TO
THE CAPITAL OR THE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS TO OPERATE
AND MAINTAIN THAT SYSTEM. AND SO
AGAIN, IT'S A QUESTION, USUALLY
A LEGISLATIVE QUESTION FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL AGENCY OF HOW MUCH DO
WE ALLOCATE THE COST OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE, WHETHER IT'S
MAKING IT BIGGER OR MAINTAINING
WHAT'S BIGGER TO THE USER. SO
JUST TO JUMP IN HERE, SENATOR,
FOR EXAMPLE, THOSE BIGGER LINES
THAT YOU PUT IN FOR THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED ALREADY TO RESIDENTS
WHO DON'T BENEFIT FROM THOSE
BIGGER LINES, WHO, IN OTHER
WORDS, IS PART OF THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS. AND SO THE
CHALLENGE IS, IS THEN YOU ADD ON
TO THAT THE FACT THAT THE STATE
HAS SAID YOU SHOULD CONSERVE
WATER. AND SO YOU BETTER FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET YOUR RESIDENTS
TO CONSERVE SO THAT EVERYBODY
REDUCES THEIR CONSUMPTION. AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT IT REALLY IS,
AN ACCOUNTING ERROR, ISSUE,
BECAUSE YOU'VE ALREADY CHARGED
THOSE PEOPLE WHO AREN'T USING
THE BIGGER PIPES FOR THE BIGGER
PIPES, BECAUSE THAT'S PART OF
THE SYSTEM. AND SO I THINK THE
CHALLENGE HERE IS, IS, IS THAT
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING WE NEED
TO WIND OUT THE WATER COSTS
BECAUSE I SHOULDN'T HAVE TO PAY
MORE, DESPITE THE FACT THAT I'M
PROLIFICALLY USING IT, BUT IT'S
NOT JUST THE WATER COSTS. IT'S
ALL OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
MAINTENANCE AND, AND, COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH IT. RIGHT. AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS,
ESPECIALLY FOR WATER AND THINGS
LIKE THAT. THOSE ARE ALL
DESIGNED IN THE BEGINNING FOR
ULTIMATE CAPACITY OF WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. YES, THERE WILL BE SOME
OLDER CITIES THAT WIND UP HAVING
TO RETRO GO RETROFIT, AND THOSE
DO WIND UP BEING ABSORBED IN THE
IN THE COST BY EVERYBODY,
BECAUSE EVERYBODY DOES BENEFIT
FROM THE DELIVERY OF WATER,
WHETHER THEY'RE GETTING IT IN A
SMALL PIPE OR A LARGER PIPE, THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THEY USE IS
DIFFERENT. AND THAT'S WHERE MY
NEXT QUESTION KIND OF FOCUSES ON
IS, OKAY, SO YOU HAVE THE
LARGER, LARGER WATER USERS THAT
ARE, HAVE HAVE SUED APPARENTLY.
AND BECAUSE OF THEY FEEL LIKE
THEY'RE BEING OVERCHARGED. AND
THAT ANSWER, THAT ANSWER WILL
COME IN THE FORM OF WHATEVER THE
JUDGE DECIDES. CORRECT. RIGHT.
WHAT ABOUT THE SMALLER ONES?
WHAT ABOUT THE PEOPLE THAT, HAVE
BEEN AFFECTED BY TIERED RATE
STRUCTURES AND THEY FIND ERRORS
IN THOSE TIERED RATE STRUCTURES,
LIKE A FLUCTUATING AMOUNT OF
DAYS THAT THE BILLING DAYS
BECAUSE THAT HAS PUSHED PEOPLE
IN. I'VE SEEN THIS
UNFORTUNATELY, NOT VERY MANY
PEOPLE HAVE CAN SIT THERE AND
DECIPHER A, A BILL, RIGHT DOWN
TO THE UNITS AND HOW MUCH UNITS,
YOU KNOW, HOW MANY UNITS ARE IN
THE ALLOCATION THAT YOU GET A
MONTH FOR THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN YOUR HOME? YES, BUT
I'VE DONE THAT, THAT MATH. AND
ONE YEAR AND ONE YEAR THEY
OVERCHARGED MY TENANTS $1,000,
$1,000 BY HAVING LONGER BILLING
CYCLES AND PUSHING THEM UP INTO
HIGHER RATES. SO THOSE PEOPLE
ARE ENTITLED TO A REFUND. HOW DO
THEY GET IT VERSUS HOW DO THESE
LARGE ARE THEY CAUGHT IN THAT
NET? AND THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION. SO THE, ONE SECTION OF
THIS BILL ACTUALLY SAYS THAT FOR
BILLING ERRORS, BILLING ERRORS
ARE EXEMPT FROM THIS BILL. SO IF
THE IF THE AGENCY APPLIES THE
WRONG STANDARD. OR APPLIES THE
WRONG LAND USE APPLIES THE WRONG
NUMBER OF DAYS, THOSE ARE
ACCEPTED FROM OUT FROM THIS
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT THOSE
ARE FAIR AND REASONABLE CLAIMS
ABOUT THAT SPECIFIC LAND USE.
THE BILL IS INTENDED INSTEAD,
HOWEVER, TO DEAL WITH THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE OF THE
RATE, NOT AN INDIVIDUAL'S,
PAYMENT FOR EXAMPLE, THAT MONTH
THEY WOULD STILL BE ENTITLED TO
PETITION THE WATER AGENCY FOR A
REFUND OF A BILLING ERROR. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IF THE LARGER LAND
USER THAT HAS BEEN PUT ON THIS
EXTENDED PLAN FOR PAYBACK MOVES?
WELL HERE. IF IT'S A IF IT'S A
REFUND, THE REFUND WOULD GO
DIRECTLY TO THAT TO THAT OWNER.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO MAKE A CLAIM
WITHIN THE REQUIRED PERIOD OF
TIME, IF THEY IF THIS WAS PART
OF THE STRUCTURE, THEN THE IDEA
IS THAT IT WOULD GO TO OFFSET
THE FUTURE COSTS OF THE SYSTEM.
THAT'S THE CREDIT APPROACH AS
OPPOSED TO THE REFUND APPROACH.
BUT AGAIN, BILLING ERRORS WOULD
BE REFUNDED. I'M KIND OF FEELING
LIKE I'M LANDING ON THE COURT
CASE NEEDS TO BE ADJUDICATED AND
SETTLED. AND THEN IF THEY'RE
LEFT OVER THINGS TO CLEAN UP,
THAT'S WHEN WE WOULD CLEAN UP
VIA WHATEVER LEGISLATION NEEDS
TO BE DONE TO CLEAN IT UP, I'M
REALLY CONCERNED, YOU KNOW,
THESE RATE STRUCTURES, TIERED
RATE STRUCTURES, THE
SUBMETERING, ALL OF THAT STUFF,
HAS CREATED KIND OF A QUAGMIRE
FOR OR FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE ALL
THEY DO IS PAY THEIR WATER BILL
AT THE END OF THE MONTH. AND
WHEN THEY'RE PAYING $130, WHEN
THEY SHOULD BE PAYING 80, AND
THAT'S NOT AN ERROR. THAT'S
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY THEY
DECIDED THAT THEY WOULD DO THE
TIERED RATE STRUCTURE AND THEIR
BILLING BILL. YOU KNOW, THE
NUMBER OF DAYS THAT THEY'RE
BILLING FOR INSTEAD OF MAKING
THAT ADJUSTMENT EVERY MONTH.
THEY JUST DIDN'T. AND SO WHEN
THEY SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE PEOPLE
THAT WERE BEING CONSERVATIVE
WERE BEING CHARGED FOR THE
AMOUNTS THAT UNCONSERVATIVE, YOU
KNOW, PEOPLE THAT WEREN'T BEING
CONSERVATIVE WERE BEING CHARGED
FOR. AND AT THE END OF THE DAY,
WHEN THEY SAID THERE WAS NO
PROBLEM, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THEY FIXED IT. AND THERE'S NEVER
BEEN ANOTHER WATER BILL ABOVE
$80. SO OBVIOUSLY THERE WAS A
PROBLEM. AND THAT'S I DON'T WANT
THOSE PEOPLE STUCK IN THIS
SYSTEM WHERE THEY CAN'T GET A
REFUND BECAUSE PEOPLE THAT ARE
RENTERS OR PEOPLE THAT ARE OWN A
HOUSE, THEY MOVE MORE THAN THE
BIG LARGE WATER USERS. SO
SOMEHOW THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET THEIR MONEY. IN THE FORM OF
A REFUND. SO IT HAS TO BE A
REFUND OR A CREDIT IN ORDER FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF OR BE ABLE TO GET
THE MONEY THEY'RE OWED,
REGARDLESS OF THE, YOU KNOW, THE
SYSTEM THAT'S SET UP. SO ANYWAY,
THAT'S JUST KIND OF MY THOUGHTS
ON THAT. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE, HEARING NONE,
SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PADILLA, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. AYE VOTE. AND REMEMBER
THAT, WHEN WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A DROUGHT, WE ASK EVERYBODY
TO CONSERVE. AND IF YOU CAN'T
GET COOPERATION, THEN WE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO FORCE IT.
AND ONE OF THE WAYS TO FORCE IT
IS YOU PAY MORE, THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT, IS THAT WE
ASK THE WATER AGENCIES TO SET UP
A SYSTEM. AND MOST OF THEM CHOSE
A TIERED WATER SYSTEM AND, AND
IT WAS RATIONALLY RELATED TO A
LIMITED NATURAL RESOURCES THAT
WE HAD AT THAT TIME. IT'S TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ENOUGH WATER
FOR EVERYBODY WHEN THEY OPEN
THEIR TAP, THIS IS NOT A PERFECT
SOLUTION, BUT I THINK IT GIVES
DIRECTION TO THE COURT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU, WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THIS BILL. PLEASE SO MOVED.
MOVED BY. SENATOR SKINNER.
ASSISTANT, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION. IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. SENATOR DURAZO, I DURAZZO
I CIERTO CIERTO? NO. DOLLY
GLAZER. SKINNER. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER 2 TO
1. WE'LL LEAVE. WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR MORE VOTES. OKAY.
SENATOR CABALLERO, DO YOU WANT
TO MOVE ON TO YOUR BILL? YES I
THINK THIS WILL BE A LITTLE
EASIER THEN I'M GOING TO TELL
SENATOR PADILLA. YOU OWE ME,
SENATOR. SO, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB 1134. LAST YEAR, THE
LEGISLATURE MADE SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES TO THE SURPLUS LAND ACT
THROUGH SB 747, A BILL THAT I
AUTHORED AND ITS PARTNER, AB
480, BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING.
THESE TWO BILLS STRUCK A BALANCE
TO PROVIDE NECESSARY CLARITY TO
LOOK TO ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DISPOSING OF LAND WERE DOING SO
CORRECTLY. UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS SURPLUS LAND ACT. AND
THE REASON THIS BECAME REALLY
IMPORTANT IS BECAUSE THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT HAS OVERSIGHT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE REAL CLARITY
EXACTLY ON WHAT HCD CAN,
PENALIZE CITIES AND COUNTIES AND
SPECIAL DISTRICTS FOR AFTER
PASSING THESE TWO BILLS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT PROPOSED
DRAFT REVISIONS TO THEIR SURPLUS
LAND ACT GUIDELINES. THIS BILL
CODIFIES A SIMPLE CLARIFYING
CHANGE PROPOSED IN THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES TO ENSURE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE CLEAR GUIDANCE
WHEN DISPOSING OF SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT CONTIGUOUS PARCELS TO A
SINGULAR ENTITY, IN THIS CASE,
SEPARATE PARCELS THAT ARE
ADJOINED AND SOLD TO ONE ENTITY
ARE CONSIDERED A SINGLE PARCEL
FOR PURPOSES OF MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT FOR DISPOSAL. THIS
CLARITY HELPS TO STREAMLINE THE
DISPOSAL PROCESS FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES. HOWEVER THE DRAFT
GUIDELINES IN MANY WAYS, IN MANY
WAYS ARE A SIGNIFICANT DEPARTURE
FROM WHAT WAS CONTEMPLATED AND
ULTIMATELY ULTIMATELY AGREED TO
BY THE LEGISLATURE, WHICH THE
STAFF ARTICULATE ARTICULATES
CLEARLY ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS OVER THE FALL, I MET
WITH HCD TO DISCUSS THIS CONCERN
THAT THE GUIDELINES WERE NOT
REFLECTIVE OF LEGISLATIVE INTENT
AND BASED ON THE CURRENT STATE
OF THE DRAFT GUIDELINES, I FEAR
HCD WILL CONTINUE TO PUT FORWARD
GUIDELINES THAT ARE COUNTER TO
THE AGREEMENTS THAT WE MADE HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR.
THIS BILL SERVES AS A VEHICLE TO
MONITOR THE FINAL GUIDELINES
PROPOSED BY HCD AND ENSURE THE
AGREEMENTS REACHED BETWEEN THE
RESPECTIVE POLICY COMMITTEES,
MEMBERS AND STAKEHOLDERS ARE
FAITHFULLY ADOPTED, ONE OF THE
REASONS I BELIEVE THIS HAPPENED
IS BECAUSE, WE HAD A
DISAGREEMENT ON WHETHER HCD HAD
TO FOLLOW THE PROCESS FOR
ADOPTING GUIDELINES THAT
EVERYONE HAS TO FOLLOW, AND NOW
I'M DRAWING A BLANK ON ON THE,
ON WHAT IT'S CALLED. BUT, BUT
THE POINT IS, IS THEY HAVE
AUTHORITY UNDER, UNDER PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION TO DO EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS, WHICH DON'T GIVE
MUCH OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
INPUT AND REVISIONS THAT YOU GET
TO SEE. AND THAT'S PART OF THE
CHALLENGE AS WAS DONE LAST YEAR.
ANY CHANGES PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL ONCE THE FINAL GUIDELINES
ARE PUBLIC, WILL BE THOROUGHLY
VETTED WITH ALL INTERESTED
STAKEHOLDERS. AND I COMMIT TO
BRING THE BILL BACK BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD ANY SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES BE MADE, AND SO WITH
THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, DO YOU HAVE ANY I DO
NOT THIS IS THIS IS MY BILL. SO.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY ANYONE WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
SEEING NONE, ARE THERE ANY
OPPOSING THÀNH WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR. BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON BEHALF
OF THE PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
PROJECT, WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION. WE'RE IN THAT
TWEENER CATEGORY. BUT I DID JUST
WANT TO TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PUT ON THE RECORD THAT WE HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE SENATOR
IN THE PAST ON ALL OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT SHE'S RAISING
ABOUT THE GUIDELINES AND THE LAW
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SLA, WHICH AS WE'LL PROBABLY
TALK ABOUT LATER IN THIS
HEARING, IS CONTINUING SUBJECT
OF CONVERSATION, BUT WANTED TO
NOTE FOR TODAY THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL. BUT AS THE
AS THE SENATOR JUST MENTIONED,
SHOULD IT BECOME A VEHICLE FOR
FURTHER CHANGES, OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GOING TO WANT TO ENGAGE ON THAT
AND HAVE A CONVERSATION ABOUT
HOW IT INTERACTS WITH THE
GUIDELINES. BUT JUST WANTED TO
NOTE THAT FOR TODAY, WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON WHAT'S BEFORE YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR WIENER? NO. OKAY.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. MOVE THE BILL. OKAY.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR DOLLY. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS? YES. SENATOR SKINNER,
THANK YOU. SENATOR CABALLERO,
THANK YOU FOR DIGGING INTO THIS.
IT'S I'LL CALL IT A WONKY BILL
FOR THE MOMENT. AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS. IT WAS
A LITTLE CONFUSING TO ME, IT
DOES SEEM APPARENT THAT SOME,
ENTITIES HAVE FELT THAT THE,
WELL, THAT THE PROCESS HAS BEEN
SLOWED DOWN, MEANING, YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY, OUR OUR CURRENT
STATUTE AROUND SURPLUS LAND ACT
DOES GIVE PREFERENCE TO A
NONPROFIT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS, BUT IT WOULD APPEAR.
BUT IT'S IT DOES NOT IT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT THE SALE OF THESE LANDS
FOR OTHER PURPOSES, BUT IT WOULD
APPEAR THAT THE WAY IT'S BEING
IMPLEMENTED AND YOU'RE, YOU'RE
ADDRESSING ENFORCED, IS CAUSING
EITHER CONFUSION OR SLOWING IT.
SO I, I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
AND I'M, I'M GOING TO ASSUME
FROM THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS
THAT THAT BY, BY ADOPTING THESE
CLARIFICATIONS THAT YOU HAVE
RECOMMENDED THAT WE ARE NOT,
GIVEN THAT I'M HOUSING CHAIR, I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE NOT
ENCROACHING ON THE, SURPLUS
LANDS ACT PREFERENCE, THE
REVISIONS THAT WERE MADE THAT
DID GIVE PREFERENCE OR PRIORITY
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING, BIDS
FIRST. SO I, I COULDN'T I DON'T
MEAN I COULDN'T, I JUST IT DOES
NOT APPEAR THAT THAT IN ANY WAY
AFFECTS IT, BUT I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE SO WANTED TO PUT IT ON
THE RECORD. THANK YOU FOR THAT.
AND IT DOES NOT IN ANY WAY
IMPACT THAT THIS IS THE INTERNAL
WORKINGS. MAYOREDLEE IS WONKY.
IT'S THE INTERNAL WORKINGS OF
HOW THE SYSTEM, OPERATES AND
WHAT WE WERE TRYING TO DO WHEN
WE WHEN WE WORKED ON THE SLA,
THE TWO BILLS WAS TO ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM WHERE YOU GOT DECISIONS
QUICKLY, WHERE IT WAS CLEAR TO
CITIES AND COUNTIES AND SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WHAT PROPERTY WAS
SURPLUS AND WHAT WASN'T, AND
THEN IF THEY EXERCISED SOME,
ACTION THAT THAT THERE WAS A
PROCESS THAT HCD SHOULD LOOK AT,
AT AS, AS PART OF THAT AND, SO
IT DOES NOT AFFECT THE HOUSING
AT ALL. OKAY. GREAT ALL RIGHT.
OKAY GREAT. OKAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR KENNEDY. YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR CABALLERO.
AND WITH THAT CLARIFICATION THAT
IF THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES
THAT COULD, BE MADE, THAT THIS
COMMITTEE WILL WILL HEAR THEM.
ABSOLUTELY. OKAY. AND AGAIN,
JUST, HOW IMPORTANT THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT IS TO CARRYING OUT OUR,
OUR GOAL, STATEWIDE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE ALL WE
ALL KNOW THAT. APPRECIATE ALL
YOU WORK ON THAT. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS. SENATOR
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO CLOSE?
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. OKAY, GREAT. CALL THE ROLL
. MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SENATORS DURAZZO I
DURAZZO I CIERTO CIERTO I DOLLY.
DOLLY I GLAZER. SKINNER. SKINNER
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER 4 TO
0 OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE THAT. WE'LL
LEAVE IT OPEN. THANK YOU FOR THE
VOTES. THANK YOU. SENATOR WE
HAVE SENATOR MANN.
SENATOR MANN JUST WALKED IN. GO
AHEAD. SENATOR, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. COMMITTEE MEMBERS, BEFORE
I BEGIN, I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF, FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS MEASURE. AND I
WILL NOTE THAT I AM ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS, SB 1174 WOULD ENSURE
THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CANNOT
IMPLEMENT VOTER IDENTIFICATION
LAWS IN LOCAL ELECTIONS. RECENT
CLAIMS OF VOTER FRAUD HAVE BEEN
MASSIVELY OVERBLOWN. I WILL JUST
NOTE THAT THE CITY THAT PROMPTED
THIS HUNTINGTON BEACH, HAS, TO
MY KNOWLEDGE, NOT PRESENTED OR
ACCUMULATED ANY EVIDENCE OF
VOTER FRAUD IN ANY CIRCUMSTANCE.
REYES AND I HAVE ASKED THE CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE
REPEATEDLY, SEVERAL TIMES FOR
EVIDENCE TO THAT EFFECT, AND SO
THIS SEEMS. LIKE IT IS JUST
ANOTHER OF THEIR UNFORTUNATE
ATTEMPTS TO TRY TO ENGAGE IN
CULTURE WARS, THERE IS AN
OVERWHELMING BODY OF EVIDENCE
SHOWING THAT VOTER ID LAWS SERVE
TO DISENFRANCHIZE PEOPLE OF
COLOR, MAKING IT HARDER FOR
SENIORS AND VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES. TO CAST THEIR
VOTE. WE ALREADY HAVE STRONG
PROTECTIONS AGAINST VOTER ID
VOTER FRAUD IN THIS STATE TO
REGISTER TO VOTE, CALIFORNIANS
MUST PROVIDE THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSES. CALIFORNIA ID NUMBER,
OR THE LAST FOUR DIGITS OF THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. ON TOP
OF THIS, AS WE KNOW, CALIFORNIA
HAS A ROBUST SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION CHECK, MANDATORY
PARTIAL RECOUNTS. AND AT A TIME
WHEN VOTER FRAUD CONSPIRACIES
LIKE THE BIG LIE THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS, QUOTE UNQUOTE
STOLEN ATTEMPT TO CAST UNDUE
DOUBTS ON OUR ELECTION
PROCESSES, CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
LIMIT VOTER PARTICIPATION. LOOK,
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE ARE
TRYING TO BALANCE TWO COMPETING
PRINCIPLES VOTE VOTE INTEGRITY,
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND THE
FRANCHISE. AND WE KNOW THAT IN A
VIBRANT DEMOCRACY, IT IS
CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE BROAD
PARTICIPATION IN OUR ELECTIONS.
AT THIS POINT, I HAVE NOT SEEN
ANY EVIDENCE THAT THERE ARE
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
VOTER FRAUD. AND AGAIN, AS I
NOTE, WE HAVE NOT SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE FROM ORANGE COUNTY OR
HUNTINGTON BEACH. I WILL JUST
NOTE THAT OUR ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY, WHO IS PRETTY
WELL KNOWN FOR BEING TOUGH ON
CRIME, WHAT YOU MIGHT CALL VERY
CONSERVATIVE ON THESE ISSUES,
TODD SPITZER HAS SAID ON SEVERAL
OCCASIONS THAT HE HAS NOT FOUND
ANY EVIDENCE OF VOTER FRAUD IN
ORANGE COUNTY, AND HE HAS
INVESTIGATED EVERY CLAIM HIS
OFFICE HAS INVESTIGATED EVERY
CLAIM THAT HAS COME BEFORE HIM.
SO THIS MAKES IT VERY CLEAR THE
PRINCIPLE THAT STATE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE THE BODY
THAT DEALS WITH VOTER ID, AND I
THINK THAT'S ALREADY VERY CLEAR
WHEN IT COMES TO ANY ELECTION
LAWS AND VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS
THAT MIGHT IMPACT, COUNTY OR
STATE OR FEDERAL ELECTIONS AND
SO ON A WHOLE, THE HUNTINGTON
BEACH MEASURE THAT THAT IS ONE
OF THE MEASURES THAT WOULD BE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL IS ALREADY
VERY CLEARLY ILLEGAL IN MY
READING OF THE LAW AND MY
STAFF'S READING OF THE LAW,
THERE IS SOME AMBIGUITY AS TO
WHETHER A CHARTER CITY COULD
IMPOSE THEIR OWN VOTER ID
REQUIREMENTS IF THEY WERE TO
HOLD THEIR OWN ELECTIONS AT A
TIME AND PLACE THAT IS UNIQUE TO
OTHER ELECTIONS IN A WAY THAT
DID NOT IMPACT THOSE OTHER
ELECTIONS. THAT IS AN OPEN
QUESTION. I BELIEVE IT'S
AMBIGUOUS. I WILL NOTE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE TAKEN THE
POSITION THAT THAT WOULD BE
ILLEGAL AS WELL. THEY MAY BE
RIGHT, BUT THAT WOULD MATTER, I
THINK IS NOT SETTLED UNDER CASE
LAW AT THE MOMENT. SO WITH THIS
BILL WOULD BASICALLY DO IS TO
CLOSE ANY AMBIGUITY HERE, TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT EVEN UNDER
THAT SCENARIO, CHARTER CITIES
CANNOT IMPOSE THEIR OWN VOTER
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS THAT
THAT IS IN THE PROVINCE OF THE
STATE. BUT WITH THAT HERE, TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
I HAVE, BRITTANY STONECIPHER,
LEGISLATIVE ATTORNEY WITH THE
ACLU, AND JOEY FLEAGLE. MICHELLE
MISHLOVE. I ALWAYS MISPRONOUNCE
YOUR NAME. SORRY ABOUT THAT.
POLITICAL ACTION APPRENTICE AT
AFSCME CALIFORNIA. OKAY. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I'M BRITTANY
STONECIPHER FROM ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION. I'M PLEASED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB 1174. THIS BILL
WOULD ONE REAFFIRM THE VOTING
RIGHTS AND ELECTION INTEGRITY,
INCLUDING VOTER VERIFICATION,
ARE MATTERS OF STATEWIDE CONCERN
AND TWO, MAKE CLEAR THAT CHARTER
CITIES ARE PROHIBITED FROM
ENACTING VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS
FOR MUNICIPAL ELECTIONS. VOTER
ID LAWS PERPETUATE THE MYTH OF
VOTER FRAUD AND DO NOTHING TO
IMPROVE ELECTION INTEGRITY. OUR
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS, STUDIES
EXPERTS AND COURTS HAVE
REPEATEDLY CONFIRMED THAT
INSTANCES OF VOTER FRAUD ARE
EXCEEDINGLY RARE AND THAT
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS IN
PARTICULAR, ARE MORE SECURE THAN
EVER BEFORE IN HISTORY. AT THE
SAME TIME, NUMEROUS STUDIES AND
DATA SHOW THAT VOTER ID
REQUIREMENTS IMPOSED SEVERE,
DISPARATE, AND UNNECESSARY
BURDENS ON VOTERS, PARTICULARLY
VOTERS OF COLOR. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS LONG UNDERSTOOD
THE HARMS OF VOTER ID
REQUIREMENTS AND STATE LAW DOES
NOT IMPOSE A VOTER ID
REQUIREMENT AT THE BALLOT BOX.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
ALREADY VERIFY VOTER ELIGIBILITY
AND ENSURE ELECTION INTEGRITY
FOR LOCAL, STATE AND FEDERAL
ELECTIONS IN A MANNER THAT IS
MINIMALLY BURDENSOME ON VOTERS
AND SUPPORTS A STRONG DEMOCRACY
IN OUR STATE. DESPITE
CALIFORNIA'S CAREFULLY BALANCED
SYSTEM, HUNTINGTON BEACH'S CITY
COUNCIL PLACED A VOTER ID
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT IN MARCH,
AND THE CITY ATTORNEY
ERRONEOUSLY ARGUED THAT
HUNTINGTON BEACH IS PERMITTED TO
IMPOSE VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE IT'S A CHARTER CITY.
HUNTINGTON BEACH'S PROPOSITION
IGNORES CASE LAW THAT MAKES
VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS INVALID,
BECAUSE VOTER RIGHTS AND
ELECTION INTEGRITY ARE MATTERS
OF STATEWIDE CONCERN, AND THE
MEASURE UNNECESSARILY BURDENS
VOTING RIGHTS. HUNTINGTON
BEACH'S MEASURE HAS ALREADY BEEN
RIGHTLY CHALLENGED IN COURT. IN
THE MEANTIME, SB 1174 WILL STOP
ANY OTHER CITIES FROM ATTEMPTING
TO PASS SIMILAR MEASURES TO
SPREAD MISINFORMATION ABOUT
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS. WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL BY
TO PREVENT CHIPPING AWAY OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IN OUR STATE. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING, MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THIS MORNING. MY
NAME IS JOEY FLAGEL MISHLOVE,
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
MORE THAN 200,000 WORKING PEOPLE
WHO MAKE UP THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE, COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, THE AFSCME MEMBERS
WORK AT ALL LEVELS OF STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. WE WORK IN OUR
STATE HOSPITALS, AT OUR UCS, WE
MAINTAIN WATER AND UTILITY
DISTRICTS, AND WE OPERATE ALMOST
EVERY FUNCTION OF CITY AND
COUNTY GOVERNMENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. AND THAT INCLUDES
MANY COUNTIES WHERE OUR MEMBERS
WORK IN OUR ELECTIONS OFFICES TO
ENSURE THAT OUR ELECTIONS ARE
FAIR, HONEST, AND EQUALLY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL EVERY YEAR.
AND SO AFSCME MEMBERS ARE ALL
DEEPLY INVESTED IN OUR STATE'S
ELECTORAL APPARATUS, BECAUSE IT
IS THEIR JOB TO CARRY OUT THE
PLANS AND POLICIES THAT ELECTED
OFFICIALS CREATE. AND SO OUR
MEMBERS KNOW THAT THEY ARE BEST
ABLE TO SERVE THEIR COMMUNITIES.
WHEN THE ELECTED OFFICIALS THEY
WORK FOR ARE TRULY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES. RIGHT NOW, WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT CALIFORNIA
IS A NATIONAL LEADER IN
DESIGNING ELECTION SYSTEMS THAT
ARE FAIR AND ARE JUST, BUT THAT
OUR STATE IS NOT IMMUNE TO
NATIONAL CURRENTS THAT PULL OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS TOWARDS ONE
THAT IS MORE ARDUOUS AND
ULTIMATELY MORE EXCLUSIVE OF
WORKING PEOPLE. CITIES
IMPLEMENTING VOTER ID LAWS COULD
TAKE A MAJOR STEP BACKWARDS BY
ENFORCING POLICIES THAT ACTUALLY
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT TO VOTE,
AND SPECIFICALLY HAVE BEEN SHOWN
TO EXCLUDE BLACK, LATINO AND
INDIGENOUS COMMUNITY MEMBERS
FROM OUR ELECTORAL SYSTEM.
FURTHERMORE, MEMBERS OF OUR
UNION WHO ARE LONG TERM CARE
WORKERS ATTENDING TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND OUR ELDERLY
COMMUNITIES HAVE POINTED TO MANY
STUDIES SHOWING THAT VOTER ID
LAWS HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT ON THOSE COMMUNITIES AS
WELL. AND SO WE KNOW THAT THESE
LAWS ARE A REAL THREAT TO A
THRIVING DEMOCRACY AND WOULD
ALLOW OUR ELECTORAL PROCESS TO
MISREPRESENT OR IGNORE
COMMUNITIES THAT OUR MEMBERS
LIVE IN. WORK IN, AND ARE PART
OF. AND THIS STEP BACKWARDS
REPRESENTED BY VOTER ID LAWS,
CANNOT BE JUSTIFIED BY CLAIMS OF
VOTER FRAUD, WHICH HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TIME AND TIME AGAIN TO BE
OVERBLOWN AND TO BE DOG WHISTLES
THAT SERVE TO EXCLUDE TARGETED
POPULATIONS FROM THE VOTING
PROCESS. SO TO PREVENT THIS
TREND OF DISENFRANCHISEMENT
EXTENDING INTO OUR COMMUNITIES,
AFSCME STRONGLY AND RESPECTFULLY
RECOMMENDS AN AYE VOTE ON SB
1174 SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO
PROTECT FAIR, HONEST AND
EQUITABLE VOTING SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA. OKAY. DO WE HAVE ANY
FURTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NØ FREEMAN WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, ALYSSA
SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
RANCHO CUCAMONGA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
MORE IN WITNESSES AND SUPPORT,
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE, BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? QUESTIONS I'LL MOVE
THE BILL, BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR SKINNER. SENATOR. YES.
THANK YOU, IN THE CASE OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH, WAS THAT AN
ELECTION THAT'S ALREADY
HAPPENED, OR IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT'S ON THE BALLOT FOR NEXT
TIME YOU'RE DIRECTING THAT TO MY
WITNESS OR TO ME? I WOULD
IMAGINE THE WITNESS. SHE SEEMED
TO KNOW THAT. OR I COULD ALSO.
I'M SORRY. NO, NO, I JUST WANT
TO RESPECT THE CHAIR'S PROTOCOL
HERE. OKAY I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER,
BUT IF YOU'D LIKE TO ANSWER, SO
IT HAS NOT. IT'S NOT. IT'S
SUPPOSED TO GET ENACTED TILL, I
BELIEVE, 20, 26. RIGHT. BUT IT'S
BEEN VOTED ON, IT HAS BEEN VOTED
ON. YES. OKAY. AND WHAT WAS THE
OUTCOME OF THAT? IT DID PASS BY
WHAT, I DON'T KNOW THE OUTCOME.
DO YOU KNOW SEVEN POINTS? SEVEN
POINTS. OKAY WHAT IS THE
DISENFRANCHISEMENT AS FAR AS
SOMEBODY, A SENIOR CITIZEN LIKE
MYSELF? GOING TO VOTE AND HAVING
TO SHOW MY ID, I HAVE TO SHOW IT
WHEN I GO TO BEVMO. I HAVE TO
SHOW IT WHEN I GO TO KAISER, I
HAVE TO SHOW IT WHEN I GO TO ALL
THESE THINGS. WHAT'S THE
DISENFRANCHIZE, MADAM CHAIR? IS
IT OKAY IF MY WITNESS RESPONDS
TO THAT QUESTION? YES. SORRY.
YES SO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE DO NOT
HAVE DRIVER'S LICENSES IN
PARTICULAR, OR STATE
IDENTIFICATION CARDS. AND THAT'S
DISPROPORTIONATELY OLDER PEOPLE.
PEOPLE OF COLOR, LOWER INCOME
PEOPLE, PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
, AND THAT NUMBER GOES
CONSIDERABLY UP. SO ON AVERAGE
ABOUT 10% OF PEOPLE DON'T HAVE A
DRIVER'S LICENSE OR STATE ID, SO
IF THAT'S REQUIRED IN ORDER TO
VOTE, WE ARE DEPRIVING PEOPLE OF
A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. BUT ISN'T
IT REQUIRED PERIOD TO HAVE AN ID
? AND IF YOU'RE A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT, YOU NEED EITHER AN ID
OR NOT NECESSARILY A DRIVER'S
LICENSE, BUT AT LEAST AN ID
EVERYBODY CAN GET ONE. I'M NOT.
I'M NOT AWARE OF A LAW THAT
MANDATES HAVING A STATE ID. I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE. YOU HAVE TO
INFORM ME. I DON'T THINK THERE
IS A STATE LAW. LET ME JUST ALSO
ADD THAT IN ARIZONA, WHERE THEY
PASSED A SIMILAR VOTER ID LAW TO
THE ONE THAT THAT WAS PASSED IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH AND IN PREVIOUS
TIMES IN CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
IN ORANGE COUNTY. WHAT WE SAW
WAS WITH VOTER ID REQUIREMENTS,
THAT PEOPLE WOULD COME UP
VIGILANTE, SO TO SPEAK, AND
HARASS VOTERS AND OBVIOUSLY THEY
TARGET CERTAIN TYPES OF VOTERS.
THEY WOULD DEMAND TO SEE ID ACT
AS IF THEY WERE AUTHORITIES. IN
ONE CASE IN ORANGE COUNTY, THAT
I THINK WAS BACK IN THE 1990S,
YOU HAD PEOPLE DRESS UP AS
POLICE OFFICERS AND APPROACH
VOTERS, AND THAT'S CALLED
ELECTION INTERFERENCE. AND THEY
SHOULD BE ARRESTED. SURE. BUT
BUT THE VOTER ID LAWS, I THINK,
END UP PROPAGATING THIS TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR. SO IT'S NOT IT IS THE
DISENFRANCHIZE AND IT'S THE
ADDITIONAL BARRIER. AND THEN OF
COURSE, THE CULTURE OF THIS TYPE
OF ACT PASSING, TENDS TO LEAD TO
THAT TYPE OF HARASSMENT. AND I
JUST ADD AGAIN, IF FOR ME THE
PRINCIPLE IS SIMPLE, IF THERE
WAS EVIDENCE OF VOTER FRAUD, WE
SHOULD BE ACTING ON THAT. I HAVE
NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE IN ORANGE
COUNTY REGISTRAR IS ACTUALLY
VERY WELL KNOWN FOR, UPHOLDING
THE BEST TYPES OF ELECTIONS WITH
THE HIGHEST INTEGRITY AND YOU'VE
HEARD FROM THE ORANGE COUNTY DA,
TODD SPITZER, WHO SAID HE'S
NEVER FOUND AN EXAMPLE OF THIS,
IT IS UP TO THE STATE TO DECIDE
THAT THAT IS NOT UP TO LOCAL
CITIES. WE DON'T WANT 100
DIFFERENT CITIES COMING UP WITH
THEIR OWN RULES THAT WILL IMPACT
VOTER ID. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT. AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IF WE SEE EVIDENCE OF RAMPANT
VOTER FRAUD, WE SHOULD ACT ON
IT. BUT AGAIN, IT'S ABOUT THOSE
COMPETING PRINCIPLES OF TRYING
TO ENSURE BETTER ACCESS TO OUR
DEMOCRACY. THE FRANCHISE VERSUS
ELECTION INTEGRITY. YEAH, I
UNDERSTAND YOUR YOUR ANGST
AGAINST THE VOTER FRAUD STUFF
OUT THERE, YOU KNOW, AND I DON'T
I'M NOT I DON'T BUY INTO ALL OF
THAT. BUT WHAT I DO BUY INTO IS,
IS ENSURING THAT WHATEVER SYSTEM
WE DO HAVE, THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN IT BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT LEADS TO PEOPLE NOT HAVING,
CONFLICT IN THE SYSTEM. AND
THEREFORE CLAIMS OF VOTER FRAUD
OR THINGS LIKE THAT. AND THE
MORE WE CAN DO TO MAKE THEM
CONFIDENT THAT THERE IS NONE,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T SEE THE HARM
IN THAT. YOU KNOW, I'D LIKE TO
SEE THE REAL AND I'LL. LOOK,
I'LL GO AND FOLLOW UP ON THOSE
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN DONE AND
WHY WHY THEY ARE THE WAY THEY
ARE. YOU KNOW, WHAT'S WHAT'S
CAUSING PEOPLE NOT TO HAVE,
ACCESS TO VOTING IF THEY NEED AN
ID, BECAUSE LIKE I SAID, FOR WE
USE IDS FOR EVERYTHING. AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE QUESTION WHY ALL
OF A SUDDEN FOR THAT, FOR THAT
OFFICIAL ACT, YOU DON'T NEED AN
ID, BUT EVERY OTHER OFFICIAL ACT
YOU DO. SO ARE WE
DISENFRANCHIZING PEOPLE FROM
GOING TO BEVMO? NO. ARE WE?
ANYBODY? SO IF THAT WASN'T A
RHETORICAL QUESTION, DRINKING
ALCOHOL IS NOT A FUNDAMENTAL
RIGHT. I JUST WANT TO GET THIS
STRAIGHT. DID YOU HAVE A
QUESTION BEFORE, OR DO YOU WANT
TO HAVE A RESPONSE? NO, I'M NOT
RESPONDING. I HAVE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT QUESTION. OKAY GO
AHEAD. JUST A QUICK RESPONSE.
VOTING IS A FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT
AND DRINKING ALCOHOL IS NOT. BUT
ALSO IT'S UNNECESSARY. WE
ALREADY VERIFY PEOPLE'S IDENTITY
WHEN THEY'VE REGISTERED A VOTE
AND IT'S UNNECESSARY TO DO IT
AGAIN, ESPECIALLY WHEN DOING SO.
MAY DISENFRANCHIZE PEOPLE WHO
ARE ALREADY UNDERREPRESENTED,
THEY USE OUR DEMOCRACY SECURITY
NUMBERS. CORRECT? SO YES, YES, I
THINK SO. THANKS. SO I JUST.
HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT SO SAY
SOMEBODY CROSSED THE BORDER. WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY ACROSS THE BORDER.
THEY DON'T NEED ANY
IDENTIFICATION. AND THEY GO
REGISTER TO VOTE AND CAN VOTE.
AND THEY'RE NOT A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA. IS THAT ELECTION
FRAUD OR NOT? YES. SO WE CAN'T
IDENTIFY EITHER WAY BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE TO HAVE ANY, ANY
IDENTIFICATION THAT THEY'RE AN
AMERICAN CITIZEN OR A CITIZEN OF
CALIFORNIA. SO THEY CAN JUST GO
VOTE. SO IS THAT FRAUD OR NOT?
THAT IS INCORRECT. THEY CANNOT
JUST GO AND VOTE. AS I
MENTIONED, YOU HAVE TO VERIFY
YOUR IDENTIFICATION WHEN YOU'RE
REGISTERED TO VOTE, WHICH IS
WITH WHAT SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. IF SOMEONE HAS A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER, IT'S ALSO
VERIFIED WITH YOUR DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR STATE ID IF YOU HAVE
ONE. AND IF YOU DON'T PRESENT
EITHER OF THOSE, THEN YOU ARE
REQUIRED TO SHOW UNDER FEDERAL
LAW, AN ID THE FIRST TIME YOU
VOTE IN A FEDERAL ELECTION.
OKAY. AND I MIGHT JUST ADD TO
THAT, I FIND IT VERY IMPLAUSIBLE
THAT AN UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANT
WOULD DECIDE TO ILLEGALLY
REGISTER TO VOTE TO VOTE IN AN
ELECTION ILLEGALLY AND RISK
THEIR STATUS HERE. I JUST I
DON'T THINK IT HAPPENS. I DON'T
THINK SO. THAT IS A GOOD POINT.
IT IS ALSO A MULTIPLE TYPES OF
CRIME UNDER STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW. TO DO SO. OKAY, MADAM
CHAIR, YES OF COURSE. YEAH. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT. I'M REALLY
SORRY THAT YOU HAD TO USE A BILL
VEHICLE TO DEAL WITH THIS BAD
ACTOR CITY, WHICH HAS BEEN A BAD
ACTOR CITY, IN A NUMBER OF
RESPECTS, WE'VE SEEN ON HOUSING.
HUNTINGTON BEACH HAS REPEATEDLY
DECIDED THAT THAT PROCLAIM THAT
IT'S EXEMPT FROM STATE HOUSING
LAWS. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS
HAD TO FILE A LAWSUIT AGAINST
HUNTINGTON BEACH, AND NOW WE
HAVE TO USE EVEN MORE STATE
RESOURCES FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO DEAL WITH THIS BAD
ACTOR CITY. AND NOW WE HAVE TO
USE LEGISLATIVE RESOURCES TO
DEAL WITH THIS BAD ACTOR CITY,
WHICH SHOULD SIMPLY FOLLOW THE
LAW. AND IT'S JUST HONESTLY,
OUTRAGEOUS. SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU. HAVE A WHOLE LOT MORE
CHARTER CITIES PRETTY SOON. OKAY
ANY MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE? HEARING
NONE. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. WE, ROLL
CALL MOTION IS. OH SORRY. OH.
MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
SKINNER. THE MOTION IS DO PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I, DURAZZO I,
SATO. SATO. NO. DOLLY. DOLLY,
NO. GLAZER SKINNER. SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER. WIENER
I 3 TO 2. WE LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
MORE. FOR MORE VOTES. OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
TO THE WITNESSES AS WELL. OH, WE
NEED A MOTION FOR THE CONSENT
MOVE. MOVE BY SENATOR DOLLY.
PLEASE. ROLL CALL. MOTION IS
ADOPTED. CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATORS DURAZZO I DURAZZO I,
SATO I, SATO I DOLLY, DOLLY I
GLASER. SKINNER I SKINNER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER WIENER
I VIÆT ZERO. ON CALL. OKAY.
THANK YOU. WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
SB 1439. I UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAVE SENATOR ATKINS.
WHICH ONE OF THE FLOOR. ONE
FOUR. SEVEN. YES. GOOD MORNING,
SENATOR ATKINS. GOOD MORNING,
MADAM CHAIR. COLLEAGUES THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB 1439, THE SURPLUS
LAND ACT ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
ASHBY. THIS BILL HAS SOME
SUPPORT BY MY MAYOR, TODD GLORIA
IN SAN DIEGO, SCRIPPS HEALTH AND
SAN DIEGO. SUTTER HEALTH IN
SACRAMENTO, PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AND MANY OTHER COMMUNITY
PARTNERS, ONE OF WHICH YOU'LL
HEAR FROM AS A KEY WITNESS. SB
1439 PROPOSES AN EXEMPTION IN
THE SURPLUS LAND ACT, ALLOWING
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES ON UNUSED PUBLIC
LAND. THE SURPLUS LAND ACTS
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK CAN CREATE
UNCERTAINTY AND LENGTHEN THE
PROCESS OF DISPOSING OF SURPLUS
LAND, WHILE IMPEDING THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MUCH NEEDED
MEDICAL INFRASTRUCTURE. WHILE
THE DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS AND MUST BE A
PRIORITY IN CALIFORNIA NHÀ,
WE'RE ALSO FACING A HEALTH CARE
PROVIDER SHORTAGE AND A CRISIS
IN ACCESS TO MEDICAL SERVICES.
IN ADDITION TO, THE PROPOSITION
THAT RECENTLY PASSED WHERE WE
HOPE TO CREATE 10,000 BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH BEDS IN THE STATE, AND WE
CERTAINLY NEED THOSE SOONER, NOT
LATER. AND THAT'S A DIRECT NEXUS
TO HOUSING, IN MY OPINION, THERE
ARE AN ESTIMATED 7 MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVING IN PROVIDER
SHORTAGE AREAS, AND ONLY ABOUT
HALF OF THE STATE'S PRIMARY CARE
NEEDS ARE MET IN 2022. IN
CALIFORNIA, THE AVERAGE WAIT
TIME TO SEE A PHYSICIAN CAN BE
UP TO 24 DAYS, LEADING TO
POTENTIALLY LIFE THREATENING
DELAYS IN DIAGNOSIS AND
TREATMENT. ACCESSIBLE AND WELL
EQUIPPED MEDICAL FACILITIES ARE
IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR
STATE AND CAN HELP REDUCE
OVERALL HEALTH CARE COSTS BY
PROVIDING PREVENTATIVE CARE,
EARLY DIAGNOSIS AND TIMELY
TREATMENT FOR PATIENTS BY
ACCOMMODATING MORE PATIENTS AND
OFFERING A BROAD RANGE OF
MEDICAL SERVICES, HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES CAN CONTRIBUTE TO A
BETTER HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
OVERALL COMMUNITY WELL-BEING. I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR COMMENTS.
MADAM CHAIR, WITH ME TODAY ARE
TWO PRINCIPAL WITNESSES. WITH
YOUR PERMISSION, LET ME JUST
MENTION CARRIE THOMAS ON BEHALF
OF SUTTER HEALTH, AND JONATHAN
PORTIS, THE CEO OF WELLSPACE
HEALTH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
YOU HAVE TWO WITNESSES AT TWO
MINUTES EACH. THANK YOU. I'M
SORRY. YEAH. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CARRIE THOMAS WITH
SUTTER HEALTH, AND I'M HERE AS
THE SPONSOR OF 1439. SUTTER
HEALTH CURRENTLY SERVES MORE
THAN 3.2 MILLION CALIFORNIANS.
AND JUST LAST YEAR HAD MORE THAN
200,000 INPATIENT ADMISSIONS IN
OUR ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS. WITH
STATE OF THE ART FACILITIES
ACROSS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST. WE WORK
DAY IN AND DAY OUT TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE LOOKING FOR
ROUTINE CARE, ALONG WITH THOSE
FACING SERIOUS ILLNESS.
THROUGHOUT THE LAST YEAR, WE
HAVE INITIATED PLANS TO OPEN
MORE THAN TWO DOZEN AMBULATORY
CARE SETTINGS, HAVE BEGUN TO
WORK TO ADD MORE THAN 160 ACUTE
HOSPITAL BEDS, AND HAVE HIRED
MORE THAN 700 NEW PHYSICIAN AND
ADVANCED PRACTICE CLINICIANS.
WITH AN EYE TOWARD INCREASING
CLINICAL STAFF, SUTTER IS ON
PACE TO BECOME THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY BASED HEALTH CARE
TRAINING INSTITUTION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WITH ALL OF THIS
GROWTH AND INVESTMENT IN
COMMUNITY, THE HEALTH CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS LITERALLY
BURSTING AT THE SEAMS OF OUR
EXISTING SPACE. IN ORDER TO MEET
THE GROWING DEMANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS NEEDING ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE, WE SIMPLY MUST BE
ABLE TO GROW OUR PHYSICAL
FOOTPRINT TO ALLOW FOR THE
PATIENT CARE FACILITIES REQUIRED
TO ADEQUATELY SERVE COMMUNITIES
ACROSS OUR FOOTPRINT. SUTTER
HEALTH, ALONG WITH OTHER HEALTH
SYSTEMS, ARE WORKING TO TRAIN
AND RETAIN MORE PHYSICIANS,
NURSES AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
TO ENSURE THAT THESE
PRACTITIONERS STAY IN CALIFORNIA
AND CARE FOR PATIENTS. HOWEVER,
WITHOUT A PLACE TO LEARN OR
PRACTICE CLINICALLY, WE FEAR
MANY OF THESE TOP TIER PROVIDERS
WILL LEAVE. CALIFORNIA SENATE
BILL 1439 WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
THIS ISSUE BY CREATING A
STREAMLINED PROCESS SPECIFICALLY
FOR SURPLUS LAND DESIGNED FOR
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUCH DEVELOPMENTS FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING, THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW AGENCIES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO EXPEDITE THE
DISPOSAL PROCESS FOR SURPLUS
LAND WHEN INTENDED FOR HEALTH
FACILITY DEVELOPMENT, ENABLING A
SMOOTHER TRANSFER OF SURPLUS
LAND TO SUPPORT THE CONSTRUCTION
OR EXPANSION OF CRITICAL HEALTH
CARE INFRASTRUCTURE. CALIFORNIA
HAS MADE GREAT, INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS IN ENSURING PATIENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE, BUT IN
ORDER TO FULFILL THESE GOALS, WE
MUST CREATE THE SPACE FOR THESE
PATIENTS TO BE SEEN ENSURING
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE AND TALENT
RETENTION OF THE TOP TIER
PROVIDERS WE HAVE INVESTED IN.
WITH THAT, WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
TODAY IS MY COLLEAGUE JOE
GREGORICH TO HELP WITH QUESTIONS
. OKAY I DON'T HAVE MY CHILDREN
HERE TO HELP ME WITH TECHNOLOGY.
SORRY, MADAM CHAIR, MEMBERS,
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY NAME IS
JONATHAN PORTEOUS. DOCTOR
JONATHAN PORTEOUS, I'M A
CLINICAL PSYCHOLOGIST AND I RUN
WELLSPACE HEALTH. WE ARE A
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER SERVING THE REGION'S
LEAST FORTUNATE. WE HAVE ABOUT
125,000 MEDICAID BENEFICIARIES,
MEDI-CAL BENEFICIARIES IN CARE,
ABOUT 10,000 ADDITIONAL
UNINSURED WHO ARE THANKS TO YOU
COMING INTO THE MEDI-CAL
PROGRAM. BUT WE ARE BY FAR THE
BIGGEST SERVER OF THE UNINSURED
AND THE LOW INCOME PERSONS IN
THIS REGION. WE HAVE A MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA IN AROUND HERE.
THIS FEDERALLY DESIGNATED WITH
TEN OF OUR 22 COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS IN THAT MEDICALLY
UNDERSERVED AREA. AND THE MAIN,
MEDICAL SYSTEM WE TURN TO FOR
SPECIALTY AND ACUTE CARE ACCESS
IS TYPICALLY SUTTER HEALTH, I'M
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE ADVISORY BOARD AND THE
CHAIR OF STEPS FORWARD, OUR
HOMELESS CONVENER HERE. AND SO
IT'S KIND OF ODD THAT I WOULD BE
HERE ASKING FOR AN EXEMPTION,
BUT I'LL TELL YOU WHY. IT'S
REALLY CRITICAL TO ME. FIRSTLY,
MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNSHELTERED IN THIS REGION COME
TO ME FOR CARE, I'M HERE
SPEAKING FOR THOSE VULNERABLE
PERSONS. I'M HERE SPEAKING FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO I SERVE, WHO DIE
ON AVERAGE, 25 YEARS YOUNGER
THAN OAN THAN OTHER PEOPLE
BECAUSE OF THEIR LACK OF ACCESS
TO CARE. AND PART OF THAT IS DUE
TO FRAGMENTATION, FRAGMENTATION,
FAMILY MEMBERS NEED TO GET
PEOPLE TO CARE. MY CAL AME CASE
MANAGERS NEED TO GET PEOPLE TO
CARE. MY CLIENTS NEED TO GET TO
CARE. BUT WHEN THEY WHEN THEY
ENTER A FRAGMENTED SYSTEM, IT'S
VERY HARD FOR THEM TO ACCESS IT.
AND THEY ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO
LOSE THEIR CONTINUITY OF CARE.
CONTINUITY OF CARE IS ACHIEVED.
THE COORDINATION OF THEIR CARERS
ACHIEVED BY BRINGING SERVICES
INTO ONE PLACE RATHER THAN
ACROSS A GEOGRAPHY. AND THAT'S
WHY IT'S CRITICAL FOR ME, SO
MANY OF MY CLIENTS AND PATIENTS
GO TO SUTTER HEALTH FOR THE KIND
OF CARE THAT THEY'RE PROPOSING
THIS EXTENSION, IF THEY CAN'T GO
TO ONE PLACE, THEY'RE VERY
UNLIKELY TO KEEP GOING TO
MULTIPLE SITES. IT'S VERY
CONCERNING TO ME, HAVING WORKED
IN LOTS OF HEALTH SETTINGS, I
CAN SEE WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO
TRAVEL, THAT WE LOSE THEM TO
CARE. HAVING IT ALL INTEGRATED
IN ONE PLACE WILL HELP THE
PEOPLE I SERVE. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? PLEASE COME UP. TARA
GAMBOA EASTMAN WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
VANESSA GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT. AND ALSO HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE DISTRICTS AND SUPPORT.
KEITH DUNN, ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
MICHAEL ALT, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE DOWNTOWN PARTNERSHIP, THE
BUSINESS DISTRICT IN DOWNTOWN
SACRAMENTO, HERE TO SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS DOUG SIEVERS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, MOIRA, ON BEHALF OF
MAYOR TODD GLORIA AND THE CITY
OF SAN DIEGO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SCOTT
WHITCOMB, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE TRADES
COUNCIL, AND THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, GRACE
COPLAND ON BEHALF OF PROVIDENCE
AND SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING
SYMPHONY BABI ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD. AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, DEON DWYER, ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO METROPOLITAN
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
REPRESENTING SIX COUNTIES AND 22
CITIES. STRONG SUPPORT BRANDON
MAKI WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. OKAY, NO
MORE, WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE?
YES. COME FORWARD AND YOU'LL
HAVE, UP TO TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS.
BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC INTEREST LAW PROJECT,
PART OF A COALITION OF
ORGANIZATIONS WHO BOTH ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THE BILL AND HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THIS
COMMITTEE WITH SENATOR CABALLERO
THE PREVIOUS CHAIR, AND THIS
LEGISLATURE, OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS TO REFINE THE SLA
AND MAKE IT AS SENATOR SKINNER
MENTIONED EARLIER, AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR THE PRODUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND THOUGH
IT'S UNPLEASANT TO BE AT THE
TABLE WITH OUR FRIENDS AT
WELLSPACE WHO DO EXCELLENT WORK,
THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS IN
WHAT'S BEEN DESCRIBED SO FAR. TO
ME, THAT INDICATES THAT WE NEED
TO CREATE A WHOLESALE EXEMPTION
IN THE SLA TO ACHIEVE ALL OF THE
GREAT WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING,
THE SLA CREATES A PREFERENCE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT GIVES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET ACCESS TO
SURPLUS LAND. BUT IT IS HARDLY A
BARRIER TO THE OTHER USE OF THAT
LAND. IN FACT, ONLY 10% OF THE
DISPOSITION, ACCORDING TO THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING,
HAVE RESULTED IN IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, MEANING 90% HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND THEN
BEEN MADE AVAILABLE FOR SOME
OTHER USE. SO THERE'S NO
EVIDENCE THAT THAT THE LAW RIGHT
NOW PRECLUDES SUTTER HEALTH FROM
OBTAINING A PIECE OF LAND TO
EXPAND THEIR FACILITIES AND DO
ALL THE GREAT WORK THAT THAT
THEY'RE DOING, WHAT IT WOULD DO,
IS CREATE A BROAD NEW EXEMPTION
THAT NOT IS JUST PUTTING HEALTH
FACILITIES ON EQUAL FOOTING WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WHICH WE
WOULD ALSO THINK WOULD BE A
BROAD CONVERSATION THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO HAVE. BUT IT CREATES AN
EXEMPTION, MEANING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ADVOCATES OR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS WOULD NOT GET
ACCESS TO THAT LAND. SO IT
CREATES A HUGE EXEMPTION THAT IS
NOT, WE THINK, NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE PURPOSE OF
THE SLA, I'D ALSO NOTE THAT
TRANSIT AGENCIES, THE PROPERTY
THAT'S A PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION, IS OWNED BY A
LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCY, HAVE A
CURRENT PROCESS IN WHICH THEY
CAN USE THEIR LAND AS AN
EXEMPTION TO THE SLA IF THEY
MAKE A CERTAIN, YOU KNOW,
CITYWIDE PLAN TO DEVELOP HOUSING
AND TO USE THEIR, A PORTION OF
THEIR LAND FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, THEN THEY CAN DISPOSE
OF AGENCY OWNED LAND OUTSIDE OF
THE SLA, WHAT WE'RE CHIEFLY
CONCERNED ABOUT, AND I KNOW MY
TIME IS UP, IS THAT THIS IS A
SLIPPERY SLOPE. IF WE MOVE THIS
BILL AND WE HEAR GREAT STORIES
ABOUT THE WORK THAT SOME AT THE
TABLE ARE DOING, WE WILL HAVE AN
EXEMPTION BILL EVERY YEAR. EVERY
PROJECT THAT IS PURPORTED TO BE
ON EQUAL FOOTING WITH THE GOAL
OF THE SLA, WHICH IS TO PRODUCE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, WILL COME
FORWARD WITH AN EXEMPTION. WE'VE
JUST BEEN THROUGH A VERY LONG
PROCESS TO MAKE THE SLA. A
WORKABLE LAW, FLEXIBLE. THAT'S
AN ONGOING CONVERSATION. BUT TO
CREATE THIS EXEMPTION IS NOT
ONLY, A NECESSARY, WE THINK, AT
THIS POINT, BUT WE'LL INVITE
FUTURE EXEMPTIONS THAT WILL
EVENTUALLY ERODE THE SLA TO THE
POINT THAT IT NO LONGER BENEFITS
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, WHICH IS A CRITICAL
NEED IN THE STATE. AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ANYONE ELSE HERE IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU. CATHERINE CHARLES, ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA, IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. CARL AND SHELBY, ON
BEHALF OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND MARK STIVERS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP,
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. OKAY, COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS? SENATOR WIENER, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. SO
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A SUPPORTER OF
THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT AND ITS
GOALS. I'VE ALSO SUPPORTED
HAVING SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THE
SLA. I ALSO AUTHORED A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT OPENS UP UP TO 170,000
ACRES IN CALIFORNIA FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, AS BEFORE.
SO I'M DEFINITELY A BIG BELIEVER
IN TRYING TO OPEN UP A LOT OF
LAND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT, IN THE IN THIS
SITUATION, THIS BILL RIGHT NOW,
AS I'VE EXPRESSED TO THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSOR, THE BILL THAT'S
IN PRINT RIGHT NOW IS EXTREMELY,
BROAD. IT ELEVATES ALL HEALTH
FACILITIES, NO MATTER WHAT THEY
ARE NONPROFIT, PRIVATE, YOU
KNOW, FOR PROFIT, ETC, ETC, ETC.
TO THE LEVEL OF THE CURRENT SLA
PRIORITY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO I THINK THE BILL IS WAY, WAY,
WAY TOO BROAD, I'M OPEN TO
SUPPORTING SOMETHING THAT IS
NARROWER, AND IT COULD BE EVEN
SITE SPECIFIC TO THE PROJECT
THAT I KNOW THAT SENATOR ASHBY
IS, IS, LOOKING TO, ENABLE WE
KNOW THAT, WE DO HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF, IN TERMS OF HOSPITAL
CAPACITY AND MANY OF OUR,
CITIES. AND SO I'M, I'M OPEN TO
SUPPORTING A SIGNIFICANTLY
NARROWER VERSION, OF THIS BILL.
SO I JUST WANTED TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE AS WE CONSIDER THE BILL
TODAY, I DO THINK THE BILL IN
PRINT, AND I THINK I AGREE WITH
THE, I DON'T WANT TO IMPUTE
ANYTHING TO THE CHAIRS, BUT THE
ANALYSIS THAT IT'S EXTREMELY
BROAD RIGHT NOW. THANK YOU.
SENATOR CIARDO. SO I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE WITNESSES HERE,
FROM THE HOSPITAL. GO AHEAD,
FOLKS, WHEN YOU'RE SITING A
HOSPITAL OR THING IS THERE AN
IMPORTANCE TO WHERE IT GETS
SITED? IN OTHER WORDS, IS YOUR
ARE YOU KIND OF LIMITED IN YOUR
ABILITY TO FIGURE OUT WHERE TO
PUT A. YEAH, WE NEED A CAMPUS
MODEL. AND SO WE WANT TO DO A
CANCER CENTER IN A NEURO CENTER
AND POTENTIALLY ANOTHER BED
TOWER. THOSE SERVICES HAVE TO BE
IN CLOSE PROXIMITY TO EXISTING
HOSPITAL, BECAUSE PHYSICIANS AND
PATIENTS NEED TO MOVE, SO IF WE
DON'T GET LAND WHEN WE'RE
LANDLOCKED, WE WOULDN'T BUILD
THOSE SERVICES. THEY WOULD NOT
GO SOMEWHERE ELSE. OKAY, I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR OUR, GENTLEMAN
FROM REPRESENTING THE HOUSING
FOLKS, YOU KNOW, THIS THE SLA
HAS BEEN IN, IN HAS GOT CHANGED,
AND IT'S BEEN IN, IN FOR A FEW
YEARS. IT'S BEEN ACT BEEN
ENACTED. DO WE HAVE ANY
STATISTICS SHOWING WHERE WE'RE
AT AS FAR AS, THE LAND THAT'S
BEEN ACQUIRED PRIVATELY VERSUS
THE LAND THAT'S BEEN ACQUIRED
PUBLICLY, IN THE WORLD OF, OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN OTHER
WORDS, HOW MUCH IS THIS ACTUALLY
CONTRIBUTING TO THE AMOUNT OF
LAND THAT IS BEING USED BY,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOLKS? YEAH.
AND THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION,
SENATOR. SO IF YOUR QUESTION IS,
DO WE KNOW, HOW WHAT PERCENTAGE
DO I HAVE AT MY FINGERTIPS? WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE UNITS THAT
HAVE BEEN PRODUCED WERE PRODUCED
ON SLA LAND VERSUS PRIVATELY
ACQUIRED LAND? I DON'T, BUT THE
ANALYSIS FROM LAST YEAR'S BILLS
INDICATED, AS I REFERENCED
EARLIER, THAT AMONG DISPOSITIONS
THAT GO THROUGH THE SLA, THE
VAST MAJORITY GO FOR SOMETHING
OTHER THAN HOUSING, BUT IT HAS
BEEN A USEFUL TOOL BECAUSE IT
HAS TO HELP TO PRODUCE AT SINCE
THOSE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE IN
THE IN RECENT TIMES THAT YOU
REFERENCED OVER 1800 UNITS OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. SO IT'S BEEN
USEFUL TO THE WITNESS'S PRIOR
COMMENT, UNDERSTANDING THAT
CETERA IS LANDLOCKED, IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO ME THAT THE ONLY
SOLUTION TO THAT IS THAT WE
CREATE AN EXEMPTION TO THE SLA,
BECAUSE IT'S JUST ANOMALOUS THAT
THERE HAPPENS TO BE A PIECE OF
PUBLICLY OWNED LAND ADJACENT TO
THEIR CAMPUS. SO IF THAT WEREN'T
THE CASE, WHAT WOULD BE THE
SOLUTION? THE SOLUTION TO US IS
NOT TO CREATE A BROAD EXEMPTION
IN THE SLA THAT WOULD APPLY
STATEWIDE, RIGHT? GENERALLY,
HOSPITALS, I THINK IN COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT, THEY'RE REALLY
IMPORTANT. THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
CITIES TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
AND SO IT'S I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT, YOU KNOW, AND
THAT'S THIS IS THE PROBLEM I'VE
HAD WITH THE SLA ALL ALONG IS,
IS ARE WE GETTING WHAT WE WANTED
OUT OF IT, OR OR ARE WE WHAT ARE
THE ECONOMIC COSTS TO DOING WHAT
WE'RE DOING? AND IS IT WORKING
TO THE SCALE THAT WE THOUGHT IT
WOULD, OR IS IT ACTUALLY CAUSING
ECONOMIC DAMAGE AND ALSO MAKING
IT SO THAT PEOPLE AREN'T ABLE TO
GET THE ANCILLARY SERVICES THAT
THEY NEED WHEN THEY'RE LIVING IN
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING COMMUNITY,
BECAUSE WE HAVE COMMUNITIES
GOING UP THAT DON'T HAVE ANY
SERVICES AROUND THEM, INCLUDING
HOSPITAL SERVICES. AND SO YOU
KNOW, FOR ME, THERE'S AN ELEMENT
OF COMMUNITIES THAT NEED TO PLAN
THESE AS WELL. AND SOME OF THOSE
INVOLVE LAND THAT THEY HAVE
OWNED AND WANT TO DO EITHER A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT, TO, TO
ENABLE THEIR COMMUNITY TO
DEVELOP WITH THE, WITH THE
AMENITIES THAT IT NEEDS TO SERVE
ALL OF THE POPULATION,
INCLUDING, THE TARGETED
POPULATION WHERE WE WOULD HAVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUILT, I, I
SEE A LOT OF HOUSING BEING BUILT
OUT THERE, A LOT OF MULTIFAMILY
HOUSING AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND IN MY DISTRICT, THERE'S MORE
LAND THAT'S PRIVATELY AVAILABLE
THAN PUBLICLY AVAILABLE. AND THE
PUBLIC IS NOT LETTING IT GO
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST NOT THE AREA
WHERE THEY HAD ENVISIONED BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND SO, YOU
KNOW, THESE EXEMPTIONS, THEY'RE
GOING TO KEEP COMING. SOMEBODY
COMMENTED EVERY YEAR THEY BRING
ANOTHER EXEMPTION. WELL, THAT'S
THE REASON BECAUSE EVERY YEAR WE
KEEP FINDING MORE AND MORE
ISSUES, THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED. BUT WE'RE NOT
ADDRESSING THEM. WE'RE JUST KIND
OF SAYING, OH, THAT, YOU KNOW,
WE DON'T WANT TO CREATE BLANKET,
EXEMPTIONS. WELL WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING. SO THE IMPORTANT,
FACILITIES LIKE THIS, WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MENTAL
HEALTH FACILITIES, IT'S A BIG
DEAL. PEOPLE DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE THERE'S EITHER THE REALLY
WEALTHY ONES OR THE ONES THAT
SERVE LITTLE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES. AND THE UN AND
THOSE, WHO, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE ACCESS AND
COMMUNITIES NEED TO RESPOND TO
THAT. AND THIS IS CREATING AN
ISSUE WHERE THEY CAN'T. SO I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY, I
WOULD LIKE US TO DO A LOT MORE
WORK. I WOULD LIKE SOME ANSWERS
TO WHERE WE'RE AT, FROM THE, YOU
KNOW, WHOEVER SUPPORTS SLA,
LET'S FIND OUT WHERE WE'RE AT SO
THAT WE CAN ANSWER THESE
QUESTIONS AND DECIDE WHETHER THE
APPROACH THAT WE'RE TAKING IS
APPROPRIATE OR WHETHER IT'S
DOING MORE HARM THAN GOOD, AND
HOW ELSE WE CAN DO THE GOOD PART
WITHOUT CREATING THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIPS AND DAMAGE THAT WE'RE
DOING TO SOME OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SO I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC
QUESTION. I THINK I SHARED WITH,
THE, SUPPORTERS MY CONCERNS. WE
THE LEGISLATURE ONLY REVISED THE
SLA AND GAVE IT. WHAT? IT'S,
CURRENT SHAPE IS IN IN 2020. SO
JUST FOUR YEARS AGO, WHERE WHERE
THE LEGISLATURE DEEMED TO MAKE
THIS PRIORITY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND TO GIVE THE FIRST
RIGHT TO THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
DEVELOPERS AND CLEARLY, WE, AS
WE ALL KNOW, AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IS A STATEWIDE NEED. WE'RE IN A
CRISIS NOW. I'M ALSO VERY AWARE
THAT THERE ARE CLEARLY THEIR
FIRST LOW INCOME ACCESS TO
HEALTH FACILITIES IS A CRISIS.
STATEWIDE ACCESS TO HEALTH
FACILITIES IS WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF DOCTORS. WE HAVE A SHORTAGE
OF NURSES. SO THAT AFFECTS
EVERYBODY. BUT IF WE LOOK AT
WHERE HOSPITALS ARE LOCATED,
THERE ARE AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT ARE NOT SO, THAT, THAT ARE
AGAIN, WHO'S WANTS TO DEBATE
WHETHER ANYBODY IS ADEQUATELY
SERVED. BUT IN OTHER WORDS,
THERE ARE CERTAIN REGIONS OF THE
STATE AND CERTAIN AREAS WHERE
THERE THERE WOULD APPEAR IN
TERMS OF, INDICATORS FROM,
NATIONAL DATA, ADEQUATE HOSPITAL
, FACILITIES. BUT IN OUR LOWER
INCOME AREAS OF THE STATE, THERE
ARE NOT SO WHEN WE BEGIN TO TALK
ABOUT, IF GIVEN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS MOVED IN THE
DIRECTION OF TRYING TO GIVE A
PREFERENCE IN SURPLUS LANDS FOR
A PURPOSE THAT SERVES OUR, OUR
LOWER INCOME COMMUNITIES
RESPONDING TO IT, LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS RESPONDING TO A CRISIS
AND THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THEN IT SEEMS TO ME, IF
WE'RE GOING TO DO A SIMILAR TYPE
OF CHANGE, AND I'M NOT
ADVOCATING THAT WE DO. YES BUT
THAT WE WOULD SIMILARLY THINK
ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS WHO IS MOST
IMPACTED BY THE SHORTAGE ON
HOUSE HEALTH FACILITIES. SO
THAT'S KIND OF SPEAKS TO THE
WELL, YOUR, YOUR CLINICS NEEDS.
BUT THAT'S NOT HOW THE BILL IS
CURRENTLY DESIGNED. AND I, I'M,
I CAN IMAGINE I DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR OUR CHAIR, BUT, YOU
KNOW, WHEN YOU'RE A COMMITTEE
CHAIR AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THESE KINDS OF, YOU
KNOW, JUGGLING ALL THESE TYPES
OF ISSUES, YOU KNOW, IT'S HARD
TO THEN IN ONE COMMITTEE
PROCESS, SAY REVAMP A BILL. FOR
WHAT? FOR WHAT MIGHT REFLECT
SOMETHING THAT IS SORT OF A
STATEWIDE NEED, BUT ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE THIS IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. SO THIS
BILL WASN'T REFERRED TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE. AND IF IT HAD
BEEN REFERRED TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE, YOU KNOW, THERE WOULD
HAVE BEEN SOME PRETTY STRONG
FEELINGS. BUT AND THE CHANGE TO
THE SURPLUS LANDS ACT THAT
CREATED THE HOUSING PREFERENCE
WAS DONE BY THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. SO THAT'S JUST ONE
ISSUE. BUT THE OTHER ISSUE IS IT
MIGHT BE THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
THAT SHOULD ALSO BE WEIGHING IN
EVEN THOUGH AGAIN, WHO'S REAL
JURISDICTION IS THIS. YES. THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT. YOU KNOW, ALL
OF THE SURPLUS LANDS ARE NOT
JUST QUOTE, WHATEVER THEY'RE
MORE THAN JUST SAY A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES. SO ON THE
HEALTH QUESTION, IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT WE SHOULD REALLY BE
ENGAGING THE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
SO I GUESS I'M SAYING ALL THAT
IN THAT THERE'S AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD THAT HAS
BEEN RAISED SO FAR BY THE
COMMENTS, BY THE COMMENTS, BY MY
COLLEAGUE, FROM SAN FRANCISCO,
BY THE PRESENTER OF THE BILL. IN
TERMS OF THESE HEALTH NEEDS, BY
THE BY OUR WITNESSES, BUT IT'S
VERY HARD IN THIS COMMITTEE'S
JURISDICTION ALONE TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THOSE. AND ALSO IN THE BILL AS
CONSTRUCT AND IT WOULD AS OUR, I
DON'T KNOW IF SENATOR WIENER
MADE THIS POINT, BUT AT LEAST
THE ANALYSIS DOES. AND SO DID
THE WITNESS IN OPPOSITION THAT
IT WOULD THEN GIVE THE HEALTH
FACILITIES OF ANY SORT A
PREFERENCE OVER THE, AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. AND SO IN THAT BREADTH,
I CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL AS
WRITTEN, BUT I'M CERTAINLY OPEN
TO HAVING CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHETHER WE YOU KNOW, WHETHER
THERE SHOULD BE SOME,
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE SURPLUS LANDS
TO ADDRESS OTHER CRITICAL NEEDS
THE STATE MIGHT HAVE. BUT THAT'S
A VERY BROAD. I DON'T MEAN THIS
A VERY BROAD. IT'S A HARD ONE TO
HAVE JUST IN WITHIN THE CONTEXT
OF THE BILL BEFORE US, SO, SO I,
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE MIGHT BE
THE DISCUSSION ON HOW TO NARROW
THIS ONE. I'M INTERESTED IN
HEARING WHAT THAT MIGHT BE, BUT
IN ITS BROAD FORM, I WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
SENATORS THANK YOU, SENATOR
SKINNER. SENATOR DOLLY, JUST
REAL QUICK, I'M GOING TO MAKE A
COMMENT. THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE DO STATE WIDE BILLS TO
DRIVE WHAT WE THINK NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. FOR EXAMPLE, HOUSING AND
LOCALS USED TO MAKE THESE
DECISIONS ALL THE TIME. AND IN
THIS CASE, HEALTH CARE IS A
PRIORITY AS WELL. IN CALIFORNIA.
VÀ. AND SO, SINCE WE HAVE TAKEN
THE LOCALS OUT OF THE GAME, I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THE BILL. AND I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
BALANCE HERE WITH HEALTH CARE
ALONG WITH HOUSING. AT THE SAME
TIME, WE CAN HAVE THEM BOTH. BUT
THIS CASE FOR SUTTER OR THERE'S
A HOSPITAL LAND CLOSE BY. FIRST
RIGHT OF REFUSAL GOES TO
HOUSING. AND THIS BILL ALLOWS US
TO HAVE OUR HEALTH CARE, TOO. SO
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. OKAY, I'LL JUST MAKE A
FEW COMMENTS. AND THEN, SENATOR
ATKINS, YOU CAN CLOSE, A QUICK
RECESS, THOUGH, AFTER YOU COME.
YEAH YEAH, BEFORE BEFORE YOUR
FINAL COMMENTS, CAN I JUST. ARE
WE, I MEAN, I THINK THERE'S, I
DON'T KNOW IF MAYBE YOU WERE
GOING TO PROPOSE SOMETHING.
OKAY, GREAT. THANK YOU. HOLD
YOUR HORSES THERE. I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE SURE IT DIDN'T GO RIGHT
UP FOR A VOTE. YEAH, AND BEFORE
WE GET, YOU KNOW, ANY FURTHER IN
TERMS OF, VOTING, I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR WHERE I'M COMING
FROM. AND I THINK MOST OF US ARE
COMING FROM THAT, YOU KNOW, WE
CARE ABOUT CALIFORNIANS. WE CARE
ABOUT HOUSING. AND THE NORTH
STAR FOR THE SURPLUS LAND ACT IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT'S NOT
JUST HOUSING. IT'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, WE'RE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS. WE'RE IN A HOUSING
CRISIS, AS EVERYBODY KNOWS IT.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, WE GET, WE
GET CRITICIZED FROM AROUND THE
COUNTRY BECAUSE OF OUR HIGH
HOUSING CRISIS. AND THIS BILL
REDUCES THE PRIORITY FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE ESTABLISHED, THE
PROPOSED EXEMPTION IS FOR WELL
INTENDED PURPOSES. THERE'S NO
DOUBT ABOUT IT. SEVERAL OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID THAT. BUT
THE NEXT BILL WILL ALSO BE WITH
WELL INTENDED PURPOSES, WHO'S TO
SAY? BECAUSE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE HAVE MANY NEEDS. THERE IS NOT
JUST THE HOUSING NEED. THERE IS
NOT JUST THE HEALTH CARE ACCESS
NEED. WE HAVE MANY NEEDS. SO
WHO'S GOING TO DARE SAY THAT AN
EXPANDED HOSPITAL IS LESS
IMPORTANT THAN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING, AND WE SHOULD NOT BE
PUT IN THAT SITUATION BECAUSE WE
NEED BOTH, THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE
TODAY SAYING THIS BILL IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE IT EXPANDS
HEALTH CARE ACCESS, BUT THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT DOES NOT
PREVENT THESE SITES FROM GOING
TO HEALTH CARE FACILITIES. AS
THE OPPOSITION WITNESS SAID,
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
GET THE FIRST SHOT, BUT AFTER 90
DAYS, IF THEY DON'T PAY THE FAIR
MARKET VALUE, THE LAND THEN GOES
TO THE HIGHEST BIDDER OR OTHERS
AT THE LOCAL AGENCY CHOOSES,
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WANT HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. RARELY DO WE
SEE THE SAME CLAMOR TO LOCATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN SOMEBODY'S
NEIGHBORHOOD, WHICH IS WHY THE
SURPLUS LAND ACT EXISTS TO GIVE
HOUSING DEVELOPER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS A FAIR SHOT.
SO, I'M GRATEFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE WAS WORKED REALLY
HARD, PUT IN MANY HOURS MEETING
WITH THE PROPONENTS, WITH OUR
OPPOSITION, AND WORKING ON THIS
BILL. SO WE HAVE SOME IDEAS, AND
I'D LIKE TO TAKE A RECESS HERE.
MADAM COULD I MAKE CAN I RESPOND
TO SOME OF THIS I AM SUPPORTIVE
OF, THE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
AMENDMENTS. WE'VE BEEN HEADING
IN THAT DIRECTION. BUT IF I
COULD JUST MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON THE RECORD, BECAUSE
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ME PERSONALLY.
I SPENT 30 YEARS WORKING ON
HOUSING, SO THE SURPLUS LAND
ACT, MAKING HOUSING THE FIRST
PRIORITY IS NEAR AND DEAR TO MY
HEART. SO I, I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S ON THE RECORD FOR ALL OF
THE HOUSING PEOPLE HERE. I AM
HERE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ASHBY.
I'VE ALSO RUN COMMUNITY CLINICS,
AND WE HAVE HOSPITALS IN SAN
DIEGO THAT UCSD IS EXPANDING,
AND THEY'RE INCLUDING HOUSING.
BY THE WAY, COMMUNITIES DON'T
NECESSARILY LIKE ANY
DEVELOPMENT, WHETHER IT'S, YOU
KNOW, IT DEPENDS. YOU KNOW, I
WOULD JUST SAY A COUPLE OF
THINGS. AND THEN I ANXIOUSLY
WANT TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE NARROW
THIS TO MEET THE CONCERNS,
BECAUSE THIS DIALOG IS VERY
IMPORTANT. I THINK IT IS
RELEVANT AND IT IS IMPORTANT.
AND I'M SORRY THAT THIS WAS NOT
PUT IN A FASHION THAT PEOPLE
COULD FOCUS IN A LITTLE CLEARER.
I KNOW THAT I KNOW THAT THIS
COMMITTEE TRIED, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. I JUST WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE OF THINGS, YOU
KNOW, GOVERNMENT INCENTIVIZES
ALL KINDS OF THINGS. AND
THANKFULLY, AFTER DECADES OF
TRYING TO GET MOVEMENT ON
HOUSING, THE SLA PRIORITIZED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT I ALSO
THINK TO THE COMMENT OF SLIPPERY
SLOPE, I DON'T AGREE. IT'S OUR
JOB TO LEGISLATE AND ADJUST
BASED ON THE ENVIRONMENTS AND
ENVIRONS AND SITUATION ON THE
GROUND RIGHT NOW, WE ARE IN DIRE
NEED OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BEDS.
WE ARE IN DIRE NEED OF OTHER
CRITICAL SERVICES. SO I DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE NEGOTIATE
HOW TO MAKE THIS MORE PALATABLE
SO THAT WE'RE SURGICAL, GIVEN
THE DISCUSSION AND RELEVANT TO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO. BUT I THINK
THAT HOUSING, HEALTH AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT THESE ISSUES AS
THINGS ON THE GROUND CHANGE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES, AND HAVE TO
PROVIDE SOME SORT OF
INCENTIVIZATION. AND I DO THINK
IT IS A CUMBERSOME PROCESS BY
DESIGN AND PROBABLY FOR REASONS.
SO I DO KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL IS PREPARED TO ACCEPT
AMENDMENTS, AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO WHAT YOU PRESENT. I BELIEVE I
HAVE A COPY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WHAT YOU DECIDE, AND AM HAPPY TO
RESPOND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
WELL, TAKE A RECESS. HOW LONG?
PROBABLY FIVE, TEN MINUTES.
BRING IT BACK INTO. OH. I'M
SORRY. COMMITTEE IS BACK IN
SESSION. SORRY. WE TOOK MORE
THAN TEN MINUTES, BUT IT WAS ALL
FOR THE GOOD. SENATOR SKINNER,
MADAM CHAIR, WE HAVE BEFORE US.
AND CLEARLY YOU COULD READ THEM
OUT IF YOU LIKE, BUT WE'VE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED NOW. A SET OF
AMENDMENTS, THAT WOULD, ADDRESS
THE. I THINK THE AUTHOR
OBVIOUSLY HAS A LARGER CONCERN,
WHICH MANY OF US SHARE. BUT AT
LEAST IN TERMS OF TODAY, THE
AMENDMENTS WOULD ALLOW THE
PROJECT THAT SHE'S SPECIFICALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT WITHIN HER
DISTRICT. IT WOULD NARROW THE,
THE WHAT WE ARE APPROVING TO
THOSE PARCELS. AND I'M
COMFORTABLE WITH, WHAT YOUR
STAFF HAS, HAS DISTRIBUTED WHAT
THE COMMITTEE STAFF HAS
DISTRIBUTED TO US AND, HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU EITHER READ THEM
SPECIFICALLY, BUT BASED ON THESE
, I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
. AND LET ME READ OUT THE
AMENDMENTS, FIRST NARROWED TO
SPECIFIC PARCELS WITHIN
SACRAMENTO. TWO IS PROHIBIT
APPLICATION TO A PARCEL IF THEY
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE SITES
INVENTORY IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT
FOR LOWER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS,
THREE REQUIRE THAT THE FACILITY
BE A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
HOSPITAL OR PARTICIPATE IN THE
340 B PROGRAM. NEXT REQUIRED
DEED RESTRICTION THAT THE
FACILITY REMAIN A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OR
PARTICIPATED IN THE 340 B
PROGRAM, THAT IT BE THAT
FACILITY FOR 55 YEARS AND LAST
SPECIFY THAT IF DURING THAT
PERIOD IT IS NOT A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE HOSPITAL,
IT WOULD BE A VIOLATION OF THE
SLA OR 340 BE SUBJECT TO THE
FINES AND THE SLA. HOWEVER, IF
THERE IS A LARGE FISCAL IMPACT
AND THIS COULD BE REMOVED, THOSE
ARE THE AMENDMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE. YES, SENATOR DARLING,
WHAT IS 340 B MEAN? 340 B IS A
FEDERAL, PROGRAM FOR HOSPITALS
THAT SERVE DISPROPORTIONATE,
COMMUNITIES, SUCH AS MEDI-CAL
PROGRAMS. AND SO IT'S A IT'S A
WAY TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
SERVING UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY MORE
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. THANK YOU
ALL, I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY,
ESPECIALLY THE STAFF, FOR,
WORKING WITH EVERYONE TO COME UP
WITH THESE SPECIFIC, AMENDMENTS
AND SENATOR ATKINS COULD CLOSE.
THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU, COLLEAGUES. AND I ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF FOR WORKING
THROUGH THESE AMENDMENTS. AND I,
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR ASHBY,
ACCEPT THESE AMENDMENTS AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. OKAY. CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. SENATOR
DURAZZO I DURAZZO I SEYARTO I
CIERTO I DOLLY. DOLLY I GLASER.
SKINNER. SKINNER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I
WIENER WIENER I620 OKAY. CLOSE
THE ROLL ON THIS BILL AND WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK. COMING BACK.
OKAY, WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK ONE
MORE TIME FOR THE PREVIOUS BILLS
.
OKAY. WE WILL BE CALLING THE
ROLL ON ITEMS TWO, THREE AND
FIVE. FIRST IS ITEM TWO, SB 1072
Dð PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
OKAY. THANK YOU. MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 1 WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS. DOLLY
GLASER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. I WIENER.
WIENER I 4 TO 1. OKAY. CLOSE THE
RULES, SECOND, NEXT IS ITEM
THREE, SB 1134. IT'S A DUE PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR. CURRENT
VOTE IS 4 TO 0 WITH CHAIR AND
VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE. SENATORS
GLASER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I WIENER I
WIENER I 6 TO 0. OKAY. CLOSE THE
RULES. AND FINALLY, FILE ITEM.
FIVE SB 1174, DO PASS, AS
AMENDED TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2, WITH
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. SENATORS. GLASER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I 42 OKAY. AND THAT'S IT.
WE WANT TO CLOSE THE ROLL ON
THAT BILL. AND, I THINK WE'RE
DONE. WE WANT TO. THAT'S RIGHT.
WE DID. I NEED TO ADD ON. OH,
OKAY. WE DID OKAY. WE DID. OKAY,
FINE. I'M SORRY. ONE MORE VOTE
AND THAT'S ON THE CONSENT. Þ
CURRENT VOTE IS 520 SENATORS.
GLASER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS I 6 TO 0. OKAY
NOW WE'RE WE'RE DONE FOR THE
BILLS FOR TODAY. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY, PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE, YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO US, TO INCLUDE
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED. AND
THANK YOU TO OUR STAFF. YAY.